monsieur le président
[Musique]
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
rapporteur
la séance est ouverte le compte rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée il n'y a pas d'observation le
procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi relative à la
reconnaissance biométrique dans l'espace
public présenté par Messieurs Marc
philippe daubrais Arnaud de belnay et
plusieurs de leurs collègues à la
demande du groupe les républicains dans
la discussion générale la parole est
d'abord à Monsieur Marc Philippe
daubrais auteur de la proposition de loi
pour 10 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois mais
ce rapporteur madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
en octobre 2020 la commission des lois à
l'initiative de François Noel buffet son
président a créé une mission
d'information sur la reconnaissance
faciale une technologie qui se développe
rapidement grâce aux algorithmes
d'apprentissage et polarisent l'opinion
publique entre les tenants d'un
moratoire sur toutes les technologies
biométriques y compris celle-là qui
serait par nature attentatoire aux
libertés et ceux qui mettent en exergue
leurs importants bénéfices potentiels
pour garantir notre sécurité
le rapport de cette mission confiait à
Arnaud Belnet Jérôme durat et moi-même
avaient et qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité avait un double objectif
combler le vide juridique qui nous rend
totalement dépendant de la rgpd de la
future directive européenne sans avoir
pu exprimer dans une loi la spécificité
française qui écarte par principe tout
recours à cette technique en temps réel
dans l'espace public
et nous permettait d'écarter touristes
en conséquence d'une société de
surveillance mais par exception en
raison en cas d'usage par cas d'usage
garantir la sécurité de grands
événements pour desquels le risque
terroriste est avéré de fait les
multiples facettes de ces technologies
soulève de nombreux enjeux éthiques en
matière de liberté de sécurité et de
souveraineté parmi ces techniques
biométriques la reconnaissance faciale
bizarre connaitre une personne sur la
base des données de son visage le cas
d'usage sont potentiellement bien sûr
illimités et les deux premières
entreprises mondiales spécialistes de
sujets sont françaises et leurs
algorithmes sont désormais fiables à
plus de 99%
la reconnaissance faciale peut permettre
notamment de contrôler l'accès et le
parcours des personnes pour les
événements sensibles par exemple les
passages de frontières c'est de
l'authentification ou d'assurer la
sécurité et le bon déroulement
d'événements à forte influence et donc
de repérer un milieu d'une foule des
personnes présentant des risques on
parle alors d'identification
de distinction doivent être réalisés
dans ces techniques d'identification
selon qu'elles sont en temps réel ou a
posteriori par exemple dans le cas d'une
enquête et également le cadre dans
lequel elles sont réalisées c'est-à-dire
police administratives ou police
judiciaires en France les usages
pérennes dans les espaces accessibles au
public sont extrêmement limités il
s'agit pour l'essentiel de rapprochement
par photographie opéré dans le
traitement des antécédents judiciaires
et du système paraphe permettant une
autotique une authentification dans les
aéroports sur la base des données
contenues dans les passeports
s'agissant de donner sensible au sens du
rgpd les données biométriques font
l'objet d'une interdiction de traitement
et ces traitements ne pouvant être mis
en oeuvre que par exception dans des cas
très particuliers avec le consentement
express des personnes pour protéger
leurs intérêts vitaux sur la base d'un
intérêt public important tout cela
relevant de la directive police justice
nous avons donc voulu avec mon collègue
Arnaud de Bellay définir collectivement
à cadre
garantissant que nous ne tomberions pas
dans une société de surveillance
c'est-à-dire comprenant des lignes
rouges et également définir une méthode
et un régime de contrôle comment en
matière de bioéthique il s'agit de fixer
dans la loi des grands interdits
applicables à tous en particulier aux
acteurs publics interdiction de la
notation sociale interdiction de la
catégorisation d'individus en fonction
de l'origine ethnique du sexe ou de
l'orientation sexuelle sauf s'il s'agit
de recherche scientifiques interdiction
de l'analyse d'émotion sauf à des fins
de santé ou de recherche
interdiction de la surveillance
biométrique à distance en temps réel je
viens de le dire dans l'espace public
sauf exception très limitée avec la des
garanties considérables pour cela nous
avons posé dans ce rapport trois
principes généraux le principe de
subsidiarité pour que la reconnaissance
biométrique ne soit utilisée que
lorsqu'elle est vraiment nécessaire le
principe d'un contrôle humain
systématique afin qu'il ne s'agisse que
d'une aide à la décision et le principe
de transparence pour que l'usage des
technologies de reconnaissance
biométrique ne se fasse pas à la suite
des personnes et soit évaluées de
manière indépendante nous avons choisi
pour ces exceptions une méthodologie
claire qui reviendrait la voie
expérimentale la proposition de loi que
nous vous présentons traduisant en cela
complètement l'esprit la lettre du
rapport considère qu'une fois les lignes
rouges définies et garanties certains
cas d'usage exceptionnels peuvent
légitimement être expérimentés dans le
cadre je le redis d'un régime de
contrôle extrêmement renforcé d'où la
propositions d'une loi d'expérimentation
sur la modèle de la loi cycle que
connaît bien
notre rapporteur puisqu'il en a été un
des artisans pour déterminer les usages
très restreints de la reconnaissance
biométrique pertinent et efficace
expérimentation pourrait être autorisée
sur trois ans ce qui obligerait le
gouvernement et le Parlement à réévalué
le besoin et recadrer éventuellement le
dispositif en fonction des résultats
obtenus voir à le supprimer totalement
pour que cette phase expérimentation
soit utile et puis cette mise en place
outre le contrôle parlementaire nous
prévoyons une évaluation publique
conduite par un comité composé de
scientifiques et de spécialistes de
l'éthique indépendant dont les rapports
seraient bien entendu rendus publics
nous souhaitons que les usages soient
autorisés à priori en cas d'utilisation
par les forces de sécurité intérieure
l'autorisation relèverait soit d'un
magistrat soit du préfet selon son
consenser dans un cadre judiciaire ou
administratif enfant le pouvoir de
contrôle de la CNIL serait réaffirmée
afin qu'elle exerce son rôle de gendarme
de la reconnaissance biométrique dans le
cadre de consultation a priori pour avis
pour les analyses d'impact et de
contrôle a posteriori du bon usage des
dispositifs et des éventueux
détournement de finalité
dans la proposition de loi que nous
avons déposée avec Arnaud Belnet fin
avril la première partie vise donc à
poser dans la loi ces lignes rouges une
fois qu'elles sont définies nous
déterminons limitativement les quatre
cas d'usage de l'identification
biométrique qui pourrait par exception
être expérimentée en premier lieu
permettent de manière subsidiaire
uniquement pour la recherche d'auteur ou
de victimes potentielles des infractions
les plus graves exploitations a
posteriori d'image se rapportant un
périmètre spatio temporel limité sous le
contrôle du magistrat en charge de
l'enquête ou de l'instruction en second
lieu institué une nouvelle technique de
renseignements afin que les services du
Premier Cercle puisse traiter a
posteriori les images issues de la voie
publique à l'aide de système de
reconnaissance uniquement pour la
protection de l'indépendance nationale
de l'intégrité du territoire de la
Défense nationale ou de la prévention du
terrorisme en troisième lieu créé un
cadre juridique
permettant là aussi de manière
subsidiaire et par exception le
raccourci blé est limité dans le temps à
des systèmes de reconnaissance
biométrique sur la voie publique en
temps réel c'est surtout ça qui fait des
bas sur la base d'une menace prale
préalablement identifiée à des fins de
sécurisation de grands événements face à
un risque terroriste ou à des risques
d'atteindre grave à la sécurité des
personnes de nombreuses garanties
entourent ce dispositif qu'il s'agisse
de la formation spécifique des agents
utilisateurs des modalités de leur
développement et de leur déploiement sur
un nombre limité de caméras dédiées et
distinctes de celles des systèmes de
vidéoprotection ce qui permet de
circonscrire fortement leur périmètre
géographique et temporel
et en dernier lieu permettre aux
autorités judiciaires de recourir à ces
systèmes en temps réel dans le cadre
d'enquête judiciaire relative aux
infractions les plus graves
s'agissant de la gouvernance de ces
dispositions nous avons proposé un
système de contrôle que j'ai déjà évoqué
juste à l'instant et comme je le redis
également l'encadrement des
expérimentations pour une durée limitée
de trois ans à côté de la promulgation
de la loi aboutit à des rapports annuels
auprès du Parlement comme nous l'avons
fait pour la loi cycine j'en ai été le
rapporteur je peux en parler enfin un
rapport final d'évaluation qui peut
aboutir à pérenniser modifier ou à
supprimer totalement les dettes
dispositions notre rapporteur Philippe
Bas a voulu rendre plus lisible cette
proposition de loi on répartit sans
différemment les dispositions du texte
afin de créer un bloc
précisons les garanties apportées les
interdits posés il a également voulu
interdire l'identification à distance
sans consentement avec ce texte modifié
l'utilisation de la reconnaissance
faciale devrait passer exclusivement par
des dispositions législatives et non
réglementaires
sachant que chaque logiciel
d'intelligence artificielle permettant
de procéder à cette reconnaissance
devrait être calibré par des crêpes et
précéder d'un avis de la CNIL ou selon
le cas de la Commission nationale de
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
et le rapporteur l'a voulu ainsi il
reviendra je pense passer devant le
Conseil d'État succédant à ce socle très
important de garantie à notre blog
défini le régime de contrôle et
d'autorisation le rôle du Parlement qui
doit être central les usages possibles
de cette technologie et
l'expérimentation sur le modèle de la
loi silt peut permettre à chacun de
mesurer l'utilité aujourd'hui d'un tel
dispositif dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
et puis un bloc sur lequel le rapporteur
reviendra puisque c'est à son initiative
et je trouve ça tout à fait intéressant
en matière de renseignements nous nous
réjouissons Arnaud Belnet moi de tous
ces ajouts votés en commission à
l'initiative de notre apporteur qui
démontre avec plus de lisibilité que
notre rédaction initiale respectait bien
les principes de subsidiarité de
proportionnalité
mes chers collègues ont terminé là j'ai
été maire pendant près de 30 ans
mon souvenir le plus douloureux c'est
celui de l'annonce que j'ai dû faire à
une famille de mes administrés que leur
fils de 27 ans avait été assassiné au
Bataclan par la barbarie islamiste et
terroriste
et je m'étais juré à l'époque comme
parlementaire que nous ferions tout pour
garantir que plus jamais sans matière de
tourisme bien sûr le risque zéro
n'existe pas mais il faut donner à nos
forces de l'ordre le maximum d'outils
pour y arriver c'est bien dans ce sens
que nous avons voté la loi silt et
qu'elle a été respectée d'ailleurs tout
le monde envoie lutter aujourd'hui et
c'est bien dans le sens que je vous dis
que nous souhaitons donner de nouveaux
outils avec des garanties extrêmement
renforcées en respectant évidemment le
rôle historique de protecteur de liberté
du Sénat je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Philippe bar rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour 10 minutes vous
avez la parole monsieur le testeur
ce président madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
chers collègues la tâche de votre
rapporteur a été facilitée par la
qualité du travail des deux auteurs de
cette proposition de loi messieurs
daubrais c'est de belles nais qui se
sont directement inspirés du rapport
qu'ils avaient présenté avec notre
collègue Jérôme Durin à la commission
des lois voici un an et que celle-ci
avait approuvé à l'unanimité je souligne
ce consensus
parce que
l'extrême sensibilité de la question
traitée ne garantissez pas à l'avance un
tel résultat si les recommandations de
nos collègues se sont ainsi imposés à
nous c'est grâce au discernement à la
prudence aux interrogations au scrupules
et même au doute qui les ont inspirés
contenu avec les données déjà détenues
sur la même personne il est ainsi
possible de ce de savoir si une personne
se prévaut d'une fausse identité ou si
une personne est présente parmi d'autres
individus dans un lieu public donné et
l'on peut procéder soit dans l'instant
pour une action de prévention ou de
poursuite immédiate soit a posteriori
dans le cadre d'une enquête judiciaire
ou d'une opération de renseignements le
parti susceptible d'être tiré de cette
technologie
est immense comme le sont les risques
qu'elle comporte du fait de son
caractère extraordinairement intrusif
tomber entre les mains de la police d'un
régime dictatorial elle peut devenir
l'instrument d'un contrôle social
généralisé
à titre exceptionnel et de manière
restrictive dans un régime démocratique
respectueux de l'État de droit elle peut
ponctuellement présenter un intérêt réel
pour la protection des citoyens à
condition que les principes et des
règles encadrant son utilisation soit à
la hauteur des libertés que nous
législateur est particulièrement nous le
Sénat de la République devons absolument
faire prévaloir j'ai abordé ces
questions avec à l'esprit quelques
références communément partagées nous
savons bien que la marche de la science
amène depuis toujours des découvertes
ambivalentes le meilleur côtoyant le
pire de la maîtrise du feu jusqu'à celle
de symptômes nous avons constamment été
confrontés à ces interrogations
auxquelles nul n'a jamais mieux répondu
que Rabelais avec qui nous disons
désormais que science sans conscience
n'est que ruine de l'âme et bien chers
collègues c'est à nous d'apporter la
conscience nécessaire à la maîtrise et
au contrôle des usages de l'intelligence
artificielle aujourd'hui pour la
reconnaissance faciale biométrique
l'Union européenne travaille sur le même
sujet un règlement européen est en
gestation il s'inspire de principes
largement comme un autre ce qui n'est
pas surprenant car la France concerne
une place déterminante dans le processus
législatif européen il pourrait aboutir
en 2025 nous vous proposons de ne pas
attendre cette échéance pour agir
la France comme elle l'a fait par
exemple avec Bernard Kouchner puis
Simone Veil il y a 30 ans dans un autre
domaine ou Science et éthique se
confrontait la bioéthique peut et donc
toi être précurseur c'est en effet pour
nous une vocation sans cesse renouvelée
que d'affirmer des principes
fondamentaux en matière de liberté dont
d'autres pourront ensuite s'inspirer
cela nous mettra en position de force
dans la négociation européenne en cours
nous avons bien sûr tenu compte du
travail accompli à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg et des réflexions engagées
par la Commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés dès 2019
ainsi que des conclusions de nombreux
rapports le plus récent très riche étant
celui de nos collègues députés Philippe
Gosselin de la Manche et Philippe Platon
nous pensons maintenant être en capacité
d'engager un processus législatif fécond
susceptible d’aboutir à l'Assemblée
nationale les principes que nous vous
proposons d'adopter son simple
relativement simple
il y a d'abord un principe absolu alors
lui il est très clair qui ne peut
souffrir donc aucune exception c'est
l'interdiction de tout exploitation
d'image issues de la vidéo surveillance
dans le cadre d'un contrôle social à la
chinoises avec classement des individus
en fonction de leur comportement dans
l'espace public en vue de les avantageux
ou au contraire de les pénaliser il y a
ensuite des principes pour qu'elle seule
le législateur pourra déroger dans des
conditions strictement limitées et
contrôlées interdiction de la
reconnaissance faciale en temps réel à
distance sans consentement par exemple
dans le cadre de la vidéo surveillance
interdiction aussi de l'exploitation a
postériori par reconnaissance faciale
d'image déjà détenues par la justice ou
la police sauf exception qui serait
alors décidé par la loi et non par
décret comme dans certains cas
aujourd'hui ces principes étant établis
le texte se penchera sur les
possibilités de dérogation sur les
finalités et sur le régime de ces
dérogations ces dérogations devrait être
prévues directement par le Parlement
elles seront expérimentales d'une durée
de trois ans placée sous le contrôle du
Parlement obéissant en principe de
proportionnalité de nécessité de
subsidiarité avec des logiciels de
traitement configurés sur la
responsabilité de l'État et
individuellement autorisés mis en oeuvre
par des personnels habilités faisant
apparaître le degré de probabilité de
l'identification avec afin d'éviter des
risques d'erreurs portant un préjudice
lourd aux personnes concernées et avec
une association étroite du Conseil
d'État et de la CNIL à l'élaboration de
tous les textes
justement comme l’ont proposé Philippe
Gosselin et Philippe Platon sera
consacré comme autorité régulatrice des
usages de l'intelligence artificielle et
sa composition sera complétée pour
associer les autorités de régulation de
l'audiovisuel et des télécommunications
à ces missions le contrôle d'accès par
la reconnaissance faciale pour être
utilisé lors de grands événements comme
nous souhaitons le faire pour les Jeux
olympiques mais de manière limitée à
certaines catégories d'intervenants
professionnels ou bénévoles à certains
lieux avec une information préalable
désintéressée sans pouvoir intégrer sans
pouvoir intégrer les riverains à ces
modalités d'accès sans leur consentement
et seulement en cas de menace
particulièrement grave pour la sécurité
la reconnaissance faciale pourrait être
utilisée aussi pour le besoin d'enquête
judiciaire d'abord pour la validation
législative de la possibilité d'utiliser
leurs connaissances biométrique pour
identifier des personnes inscrites dans
le fichier des antécédents Judici
ensuite pour l'exploitation d'image de
vidéo surveillance déjà recueillie et
cela en vue seulement de réprimer le
terrorisme des trafics d'armes les
atteintes aux personnes punies de plus
de 5 années d'emprisonnement et aussi
pour la recherche de criminels en fuite
ou de personnes disparues enfin dans des
conditions tout à fait exceptionnelles
limitées au crime les plus graves à la
disparition de mineurs à la lutte contre
le terrorisme et la défense des intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation la justice
pourra recueillir des images par des
caméras dédiées et les exploiter en
temps réel par la reconnaissance
faciales pour assurer le succès de
l'enquête au lieu de devoir utiliser
seulement des images préexistantes dans
ce cas il faudra l'autorisation d'un
magistrat qui ne pourra être renouvelé
au-delà de 48 heures qu'avec l'accord du
juge des libertés seuls les officiers de
police judiciaires qui plus est
spécialement habilités pour pourront
mettre en oeuvre le traitement enfin
l'utilisation de la reconnaissance
faciale dans des activités de police
administrative c'est-à-dire de police
préventive sous l'autorité du
gouvernement se fera sur ma proposition
dans des conditions centralisées et non
sur simple décision de préfet et donc
c'est le premier ministre après avis de
la Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement et sous le
contrôle du Conseil d'État qui prendra
la décision cette système robuste
issu de la loi de 2015 qui a fait ses
preuves mes chers collègues les
questions que nous avons à traiter
aujourd'hui sont en apparence technique
et juridique et pourtant elles sont plus
encore d'essence politique et éthique la
prof de la commission des lois conforte
je le crois les intentions équilibrées
des auteurs de ce texte tout en étendant
les garanties qu'ils y avait déjà
inscrites le caractère expérimental de
cette proposition de loi comme nous
l'avons déjà décidé en matière de
terrorisme présente l'intérêt de suivre
l'évolution d'une technologie que l'on
dit mature mais qui n'est pas à l'abri
d'erreurs et nous permettra aussi
d'évaluer les éventuelles difficultés de
mise en œuvre de nous appuyer sur une
jurisprudence et finalement de vérifier
que nous avons trouvé le bon équilibre
puisque nous avons l'audace de cette
première étape ayant aussi l'humilité
d'accepter que notre œuvre ne soit pas
pleinement aboutie et de prévoir
qu'elles puissent être encore améliorée
à la lumière de l'expérience
merci Monsieur le testeur
la parole est maintenant madame
Dominique Faure ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité vous avez la parole madame la
ministre
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la commission
des lois François Noël buffet monsieur
le rapporteur sur le sénateur Philippe
bas messieurs les auteurs de cette ppm
marque Philippe daubrais et Arnaud de
belney Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs la reconnaissance biométrique
constituée à l'évidence une technologie
aussi puissante par les opportunités
qu'elle ouvre que sensible par les
questions qu'elle soulève vous l'avez
dit la sensibilité de ce sujet nous
impose donc prudence et mesure dans les
évolutions que nous pouvons amener vous
savez combien le gouvernement est
déterminé à faire avancer vite les
sujets qu'il exigent comme la
transformation écologique la formation
des jeunes en passant par la
souveraineté énergétique mais il est des
sujets dans la complexité justifie
peut-être que nous différions un peu les
décisions définitives même lorsqu'on
pense disposer de propositions
judicieuses la reconn biométrique en
fait partie
je rappelle que vous venez de voter le
cadre juridique pour une expérimentation
du recours à l'intelligence artificielle
pour concourir à la sécurisation des
Jeux Olympiques en 2024 dans ce cadre et
le gouvernement et le Sénat ont fait
preuve de prudence et de mesure le
gouvernement d'abord qui a proposé un
texte extrêmement cadré avec des
garanties nombreuses une durée très
limitée des finalités de recours à l'IA
réduites et l'exclusion de la
reconnaissance faciale votre assemblée
ensuite qui après avoir envisagé
d'élargissement du périmètre de cette
expérimentation à la reconnaissance
faciale sur proposition du sénateur de
braise a finalement jugé plus opportun
de renvoyer ce sujet à une discussion de
fond
certains importants de travail
transpartisans avaient été mené sous la
férule des sénateurs Marc-Philippe
daubraise Arnaud de Bennet et Jérôme du
Rhin dont je salue l'implication mais
aussi la hauteur de vue
mais le gouvernement est d'avis que
l'équation n'a pas fondamentalement
changé par rapport à l'examen de loi
Jeux Olympiques il y a quelques mois et
que les objections qui ont été formulées
demeurent en effet il nous semble
important de nous interroger sur la
temporalité de cette proposition de loi
d'un point de vue politique
juridique et opérationnel
d'un point de vue politique d'abord
car légiférer maintenant sur la
reconnaissance biométrique précisément
alors que va s'engager la négociation
entre le Conseil et le Parlement
européen sur le projet de règlement ria
de règlement
Ia dont le périmètre est encore assez
mouvant pour erisquer d'affaiblir notre
position de négociation en effet il
pourrait exister un décalage inévitable
entre nos positions à Bruxelles et le
texte voté à Paris d'un point de vue de
cohérence et de lisibilité de notre
droit ensuite
puisque cette concomitance de calendrier
nous obligera en toute état de cause à
revenir sur une législation nationale à
peine votée le règlement devant être
adopté au niveau européen d'ici la fin
de l'année et traduit en droit interne
d'ici 2025 au plus tard une
configuration loin d'être optimale en
termes de prévisibilité de la norme à
Forterie pour une expérimentation dont
la durée est fixée à trois ans vous en
conviendrez avec moi je sais combien
votre assemblée a été sensible à la
nécessité d'offrir à nos acteurs
industriels un cadre juridique stabilisé
et clair permettant à la France de
disposer de solutions souveraines
légiférer maintenant nous paraît
cependant raté la cible les entreprises
étant réticentes à investir dans une
dans une exigeante démarche de
compliance si elle craignent que le
cadre puisse encore évoluer beaucoup un
ou deux ans après
d'un point de vue maintenant
opérationnel enfin le tempo de la
proposition ne nous paraît pas le plus
opportun toutes nos forces sont
mobilisées vers la sécurisation des Jeux
Olympiques
depuis que vous avez donné mandat au
gouvernement pour expérimenter l'IA le
ministère de l'Intérieur travaille jour
et nuit d'ailleurs en très bon
intelligence avec la CNIL afin d'être au
rendez-vous tout simplement de cette
expérimentation elle est complexe et
elle soulève des questions
opérationnelles importantes avec des
défis de coordination entre tous les
acteurs de la sécurité des futurs grands
événements l'État les communes les RATP
la SNCF
il ne paraît ni opportun ni possible de
distraire les forces de sécurité de ce
chantier majeur pour s'investir dans la
reconnaissance faciale dont je rappelle
que le gouvernement n'avait de son
propre chef pas proposé l'utilisation à
l'occasion des JO
l'expérimentation proposée dans ce texte
serait en outre nécessairement décevante
car sur les trois années dont le
gouvernement disposerait il n'aurait en
réalité ni le temps ni les ressources
pour s'y engager pleinement
ceux d'autan qu'il aurait à cet égard un
peu le même raisonnement que les
entreprises nationales dans ce domaine
entre un règlement Ia en fin de
négociation appelée à devenir rapidement
la référence européenne et un cadre
français dont l'extinction est prévue à
court terme et qui ne diront pas
exactement la même chose le bon sens
commandera de faire plutôt application
des règles européennes en outre en cette
matière le recours à la biométrie a des
fins de police administratives et
judiciaire ne peut se plante de manière
isolée mais s'inscrit dans une stratégie
plus large de politique de sécurité la
biométrie ne constitue qu'une brique qui
doit s'intégrer dans une doctrine
opérationnelle et dans un cadre
juridique d'action des forces de
sécurité intérieure je crois que les
auditions que vous avez menées tant dans
le cadre de votre rapport de l'an
dernier que dans le cas des examens de
votre commission sous la conduite de
vous monsieur le rapporteur voulons très
probablement confirmé il est difficile
voire impossible de se prononcer dans
l'absolu sur le recours à la biométrie
sans avoir une vision claire de toute la
chaîne stratégique et de tout le cadre
technique ainsi s'il est intéressant en
théorie de pouvoir faire appliquer de la
reconnaissance faciale sur des caméras
pour vérifier si un individu dangereux
se trouve dans un lieu où il n'est pas
censé être cela soulève en pratique des
questions extrêmement lourdes les
réponses à y apporter doivent
conditionner la conception de la norme
et non l'inverse nous semble-t-il qui
décide de la liste des gens dangereux
quelle caméra dans un contexte où ce
sont les communes et les acteurs privés
qui représentent 98% du parc de caméra
dans notre pays quel service peuvent
mettre en oeuvre cette technologie un
cadre juridique conçu qui serait trop en
décalage avec la vraie vie des services
de sécurité d'enquête risque de rater sa
cible car les possibilités qu'il offrira
ne répondront pas aux besoins de terrain
à cet égard si je salue le travail du
rapporteur il me semble que l'État est
le mieux à même pour déterminer ces
éléments de doctrine opérationnelle qui
permettrait en outre de bénéficier du
regard du Conseil d'État et de la CNIL
de façon générale la logique de la
proposition de loi par du principe posé
que tous les usages de la biométrie dans
l'espace public soulève les mêmes
questions alors que les problématiques
opérationnelles et les nécessités de
légiférer ne nous paraissent pas les
mêmes ainsi nous regrettons que le texte
ne distingue pas plus nettement ce qui
constitue l'usage a priori le plus
complexe à savoir la reconnaissance
faciale en temps réel à des fins de
police administratives d'usage beaucoup
moins attentats comme la recherche d'un
individu dans le cadre d'une enquête ce
faisant votre commission a voulu faire
relever de la loi tout traitement qui
recourait à la biométrie ce qui
rigidifiera considérablement le doigt le
droit des traitements de données cette
idée est à rebours des exigences
européennes dans ce domaine qui nous
font de plus en plus obligations de
recueillir et d'inscrire de la donnée
biométrique pour assurer
interopérabilité et la fiabilisation des
fichiers et cette approche est
frontalement contraire à la
recommandation numéro 18 de votre
rapport qui proposait à savoir et je
vous cite de mettre en place par la
prise de décret en Conseil d'État la
possibilité pour les forces de sécurité
nationale d'interroger à l'occasion
d'une enquête judiciaire ou dans un
cadre de renseignements certains
fichiers de police par le biais
d'éléments biométriques vous l'aurez
compris Mesdames et Messieurs que global
si le gouvernement salue la volonté de
votre assemblée de traiter ces sujets et
je salue particulièrement le sénateur de
braise donc nous connaissons
l'engagement sur les sujets régaliens de
sécurité et sans souci de garantir au
ministère de l'Intérieur les moyens de
son action et si nous souscrivons à
l'utilité de les traiter nous ne sommes
pas pleinement convaincus de
l'opportunité de légiférer maintenant il
nous paraîtrait plus juste au ministre
de l'Intérieur et à moi-même de renvoyer
un projet de loi en capitalisant sur
votre travaux bien sûr néanmoins malgré
toutes ces réserves et pour souligner la
qualité de vos travaux
nous émettons un avis de sagesse sur
votre texte je vous remercie
très bien merci madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Arnaud de
Bellay pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 8 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre chers
collègues chaque marque Philippe de
Bresse
ou là
ou là c'est souvent la réaction que ce
site l'évocation de la reconnaissance
biométrique et d'un débat sur la
reconnaissance biométrique
et
peut-être que s'il n'a pas été
intégré
lors des échanges
sur le projet de loi Jeux olympiques de
2024 c'est parce qu'il y a cette crainte
de susciter des réactions irrationnelles
des jeux de posture
et ça me fait souvent penser à se
personnage d'Elisa qui qui disait
réfléchissez à commencer à brûler la
langue de bois et ayez le courage
d'affronter les débats irrationnels et
c'est ce que nous faisons collectivement
et je vous remercie madame la ministre
d'envisager l'évolution d'un texte en
projet de loi je vais vous faire
observer qu'il arrive aussi que
certaines initiatives gouvernementales
prennent la forme de proposition de loi
et il arrive aussi que certaines
propositions de loi souhaitent amender
améliorer dans le cadre par le
gouvernement dans le cadre d'un échange
avec le Parlement et j'espère que c'est
ce que nous sommes en train de commencer
à initier aujourd'hui car le
développement rapide des technologies de
reconnaissance biométrique nécessite
maintenant
et c'est le moment la réappropriation
par les pouvoirs publics pour ne pas les
laisser à seulement d'opérateurs privés
ils impliquent également à débat public
que beaucoup demandés pour que
collectivement nous puissions choisir la
société dans laquelle nous souhaitons
vivre et non pas la subir et je vous
remercier chaleureusement
le président de la commission des lois
François Noël buffet nous avoir d'avoir
pris l'initiative de nous confier cette
mission
marque Philippe Debré sur Home Turin et
moi-même je vous remercier nos collègues
marquent de Brest et Jérôme du Rhin pour
le travail que nous avons
mené avec un souci constant d'équilibre
c'est ce même équilibre cette
préoccupation de d'équilibre qui a
conduit un très grand nombre de nos
collègues du groupe LR et de l'Union
centriste à cossigné ce texte et comme
c'est au nom de l'Union centriste que je
m'exprime cet après-midi je vais vous
dire qu'il soutient
cette initiative de proposition de loi
et puis saluer aussi la position
très rationnelle et
[Musique]
répondérée et très très unanime de la
commission des lois lors de la remise de
notre rapport
je vous remercier évidemment également
notre rapporteur pour son expertise son
exigence évidemment son travail et lui
dire que comme à la coutumée ma
reconnaissance à son égard n'est pas
seulement faciale pour le coup il
fallait bien quelqu'un la fasse
la proposition de loi que nous avons
déposé transcrit les conclusions des
travaux de la mission d'information
précités et poursuit à ce titre deux
objectifs principaux d'une part répondre
aux besoins de régulation de ce système
et d'autre part accorder au pouvoir
public l'autorisation exceptionnelle
d'utiliser ces technologies de les
comprendre de les maîtriser d'en tester
l'utilité le principe et l'interdiction
l'expérimentation
l'exception remanier par la commission
des lois l'article 1 pose clairement
l'interdit du traitement des données
biométriques au sein d'identifier une
personne à distance dans l'espace public
et dans les espaces accessibles au
public
sauf évidemment à y consentir cranter
cette interdit et l'écrire dans la loi
de manière durable n'est pas seulement
nécessaire cela constitue un marqueur
civilisationnel il n'y a pas d'heure
pour faire ce choix il n'y a pas de bons
moments il n'y a pas de mauvais moment
pour faire ce choix c'est le signe d'un
choix politique de société comme nous en
faisons finalement assez rarement
habituellement nous excellons dans la
technique juridique là nous faisons un
choix politique très clair refusé une
société de surveillance mieux selon les
mots choisis par Philippe Bas lui faire
obstacle garantir les libertés publiques
et puis l'interdit corollaire
la catégorisation la notation à partir
de données biométriques sont évidemment
inscrites les expérimentations sont
elles à l'inverse très encadrée elles
sont limitées dans le temps trois ans
elles sont régulièrement évaluées dans
le cadre d'un rapport public et par le
Parlement elles sont soumises à un
régime de contrôle les usages de la
reconnaissance biométrique dans l'espace
public répond à une procédure
d'autorisation spécifique les magistrats
pour l'usage judiciaires et la
Commission nationale du contrôle des
techniques de renseignement pour les
usages administratifs s'agissons des
usages judiciaires la Commission a
estimée que le recours à la
reconnaissance biométrique ne devait
être expérimenté que dans le cadre des
enquêtes et instructions portant sur des
X sur des infractions d'une
exceptionnelle gravité et en conséquence
elle a fortement très fortement
resserrer le périmètre de
l'expérimentation que ce soit dans le
cadre de la reconnaissance biométrique a
posteriori elle ne pourrait être
utilisée que dans le cadre des enquêtes
portant sur des faits de terrorisme de
trafic d'armes d'atteinte aux personnes
punies d'au moins 50 prisons ou des
procédures de recherche de personnes
disparues ont en fuite et dans le cadre
de la reconnaissance biométrique en
temps réel la Commission a considérer
que cet usage ne pouvait concerner que
les cas les plus extrêmes enquête
portant sur des faits terrorisme
d'atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux de
la nation sur des infractions relatives
à la criminalité organisée ou sur des
disparitions de personnes mineures
la Commission a également entendu
renforcer au maximum le régime de
contrôle de cette expérimentation ainsi
que les garanties associées à ainsi
soumis l'usage a postériori à une
autorisation express l'autorité
judiciaire qui devra préciser l'origine
et la nature des données exploitées elle
a également confié au seul juge des
libertés de la détention le soin de
procédure renouvellement de
l'autorisation de recourir au traitement
biométrique en question il s'agissant
des usages administratifs elle a
restreint le champ d'expérimentation en
prévoyant que le système
d'authentification
biométrique obligatoire ne pourrait
concerner les habitants des zones
concernées elle a également précisé que
seul l'État pourrait mettre en oeuvre
des traitements de données biométriques
utilisées dans le cadre de
expérimentation et c'est important à
souligner car il s'agit bien aussi de
notre souveraineté il ne s'agirait pas
que toute une série de technologie
fausses de législation partent à
l'étranger
il faut plus précisément que l'État
maîtrise ces technologies pour pouvoir
exercer son contrôle légitime et
protéger nos libertés publiques nous
étions et forcés avec marphy de presse
et ceux qui nous ont accompagnés d'être
particulièrement
restrictif et exigeant sur les
conditions de l'expérimentation
la commission
grâce aux initiatives de notre
rapporteur à réussi à aller plus loin et
j'y vois là
un gage considérable un gage donné à
ceux qui pourraient s'inquiéter pour nos
libertés
et j'y vois une bonne façon de faire
démarrer ce nécessaire débat et pour une
bonne façon d'initier le parcours de ces
textes tout aussi nécessaire je vous
remercie chers collègues de votre
attention
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant ce Jean-Claude Roquier pour
le groupe RDSE vous avez la parole
monsieur le président
c'est le président ministre monsieur le
Président de la caution des lois
monsieur le rapporteur
mitigé en découvrant cette proposition
de loi il y a quelques semaines lors de
l'examen du texte sur les Jeux
Olympiques et olympiques 2024 nous
avions admis l'expérimentation de
l'utilisation de la vidéoprotection dite
intelligente ou augmenter à travers le
traitement par algorithme des images
d'ailleurs c'est une nouveauté juridique
suivez les recommandations formulées par
nos collègues Marc-Philippe Arnaud
Bellani et Jérôme Durin dans leur
rapport intitulé la reconnaissance
biométrique dans l'espace public mais
lorsque nous avons le texte organisant
les Jeux Olympiques il m'a semblé qu'une
limite avait été fixée il s'agissait
d'une bonne limite celle de ne pas aller
jusqu'à la biométrie
permis d'indiquer lors de la discussion
générale mon sentiment profond que
l'idée présenta l'innovation
technologique comme une solution
évidente demeurer une chimère
potentiellement dangereuse mais vous
proposez donc dans ce nouveau texte
d'expérimenter le recours à la biométrie
et cela m'inspire une première marque
pourquoi ne pas désire laisser vivre
l'expérimentation des algorithmes avant
de nous engager dans une nouvelle voie
d'autant que si la technologie peut
aider nous nous comblons mais elle est
aussi facteur de dérive c'est dérives
nous pouvons déjà observer certaines je
pense en particulier à ce que la Chine
développe depuis des années ainsi
exemple entre guillemets chinois nous
parlons d'un système étatique de crédit
social qui consiste à l'attribution
d'une autre citoyen en fonction de leur
comportement il repose une collecte des
données sur les personnes sur
comportement dans la rue ou dans les
transports tout cela donne une autre qui
permet d'identifier la qualité des
citoyens et d'en déduire le périmètre de
ces droits et pour y parvenir l'usage de
la biométrie leur essentiel nous sommes
déjà dans ce que les scénarios
d'anticipation les plus préoccupants
pouvaient proposer et à peine quelques
années aussi j'avais la répliquer cette
tribune le groupe RDSE est ferment
attaché aux libertés
par les auteurs la proposition de loi
qui est notre rapporteur sont évidemment
à saluer d'autant qu'il est
inenvisageable de ne pas gestir dans la
loi elle tient compte des inquiétudes et
des risques incorrups par notre société
je pense à l'interdiction des
catégories de catégoriser les personnes
sur la base de leur donner biométrique à
l'interdiction de noter des personnes
toujours sur la base de ces données ou
encore l'interdiction des systèmes de
reconnaissance biométrique entre en
temps réel ou à partir du riz dans
l'espace public seulement tout le monde
sait bien que ce que le législateur fait
il peut le défaire c'est garde fou sont
indispensables mais ils seront
insuffisants le jour où il sera question
de les faire sauter j'avais maintenant
la série d'expérimentation qui propose
le texte chacun s'accordera autour de la
nécessité de sécuriser les événements
particulièrement exposés à des risques
d'acte terroristes ou à des risques
d'atteintes graves la sécurité des
console je pense bien sûr aux Jeux
olympiques et au paralympiques chacun
s'accorde également avoir facilité la
contestation des infractions à la loi
pénale le rassemblement des preuves de
ces infractions et la recherche de leurs
auteurs bref en quelques mots les
expérimentations proposées pour suivre
toutes débuts légitime et dans la
gravité est telle qu'elle justifie
certaines notions en matière de
surveillance ou d'investigation si c'est
des positifs devaient être restitués il
faudrait effectivement les accompagner
comme propriété d'ailleurs d'un comité
scientifique éthique chargé d'évaluer
régulièrement l'application des mesures
tout comme je suis aussi rassuré
d'observer que la CNIL serait associée à
ce dispositif comme chef de fil de la
régulation des systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle c'était qu'il est donc une
recherche d'équilibre il est en
destituer des garde-fous ce qui empêche
pas de plaider pour une forme de
prudence aussi malgré les réserves assez
importantes quant au développement de la
biométrie et même si la position de
notre groupe n'est pas unanime mais
c'est soit le cas une partie majoritaire
d'entre nous votera en faveur de ce
texte
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est maintenant monsieur Stéphane
lerudulier pour le groupe les
républicain pour 7 minutes
la parole chers collègues
sur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois se rapporteur mes chers
collègues la proposition de loin de nos
collègues Marc Philippe de Bresse et
Arnaud de bellaunay qui nous est soumise
cet après-midi est une initiative
inédite en matière de technologie
biométrique et c'est une première
traduction législative d'un encadrement
de l'utilisation de ces technologies qui
manqueraient cruellement à notre arsenal
juridique ce texte
a une réelle ambition celle de garantir
le juste équilibre entre outils
technologique de sécurité collective et
respect de l'État droit et des libertés
fondamentales dans l'intérêt bien
évidemment de nos concitoyens
en venant poser un principe
d'interdiction qui fera l'objet d'une
liste d'exception strictement encadrée
par des procédures des garanties de
surveillance collective et transparentes
cette proposition de loi est le résultat
d'une réflexion parlementaire qui a fait
l'objet déjà de trois rapports ces
derniers années travail remarquable de
notre rapporteur le testeur Philippe Bas
est venu renforcé par faire l'esprit de
cette initiative législative et le Sénat
a aujourd'hui l'occasion de faire entrer
si j'ose dire la France dans le nouveau
millénaire en matière de sécurité
alors j'entends les doutes les
interrogations légitimes de certains qui
expriment leur crainte d'un soi-disant
état policier qui s'introduirait grâce à
la technologie dans l'intimité de chacun
pour nous espionner voir pour nous punir
après les vaccins qui inoculeraient des
puces brevetés par Bill Gates la
vidéoprotection avec reconnaissance
faciale dans l'espace public violerait
notre intimité
c'est une possibilité d'où un
encadrement strict de son utilisation
mais à vous on le il y a là un paradoxe
insensé
nous acceptons chaque jour de céder à
des multinationales étrangères la
moindre donnée personnelle récoltée par
nos téléphones nos téléviseurs et
enceintes connectées ou encore
maintenant nos voitures intelligentes
mais nous refusons que l'État régalien
assure notre sécurité par tout moyen
technologique la vidéoprotection avec
reconnaissance faciale alors même que
tel est sa mission on donne à des
startups californiennes son empreinte
digitale l'identification de son visage
ou à travers des enceintes connectées
l'accès à notre intimité depuis notre
salon et on refuserait à l'état
d'assurer notre protection dans l'espace
public sous contrôle de la CNIL et du
Parlement
non mes chers collègues la
reconnaissance faciale et biométrique
n'est qu'une goutte d'eau n'est qu'un
balbutiement dans les avancées de
l'intelligence artificielle nous le
voyons bien avec chaque GPT l'IA et la
révolution du millénaire et nous ne
pouvons rester spectateurs impuissants
Retif au progrès sans encadrer
l'utilisation de ces technologies la
France doit être au rendez-vous de
l'histoire c'est ce que fait de nombreux
pays comme l'Israël le Royaume-Uni
l'Allemagne ou encore les États-Unis
pour protéger leur population face à
l'explosion de la criminalité organisée
et bien sûr le terrorisme nous avons le
devoir de l'offrir aux citoyens français
également
mais permettez-moi d'être très inquiet
quand je constate le sous-équipement des
principales grandes villes françaises en
matière de vidéoprotection et pourtant
c'est dans ces métropoles où se
concentrent la criminalité la violence
et le terrorisme rendez-vous compte
seulement 19 caméras pour 10 000
habitants à Marseille ou à Paris
11 caméras pour 10000 habitants pour la
troisième ville de France Lyon et 9
caméras pour 10 000 habitants en ce qui
concerne Toulouse alors même que dans le
même temps deux capitales européennes
majeurs que sont Londres et Berlin
dénombre respectivement 180 et 110
caméras pour 10000 habitants nous sommes
clairement en retard par rapport à nos
pays voisins et comment imaginer Paris
et Marseille accueillant dans les
prochains mois la Coupe du monde de
rugby une messe du pape ou encore les
Jeux Olympiques soient quasiment nu en
termes de vidéosprotection au-delà de
ces grands événements rappelons tout de
même que la France est le pays le plus
touristique du monde avec 89 millions de
visiteurs par an la gare du Nord est la
plus fréquentée d'Europe avec 700 000
voyageurs qui passent quotidiennement
nous devons garantir une protection dans
l'espace public à l'échelle de notre
votre activité la France doit s'adapter
à son époque on ne peut lutter contre
les délinquants et contre les
terroristes du 21e siècle avec des
outils désuète obsolètes ou du milieu du
20e siècle j'aimerais conclure par ce
que disait Clémenceau qui fit tant pour
notre sécurité collective il faut savoir
ce que l'on veut quand on le sait il
faut avoir le courage de le dire et
quand on le dit il faut avoir le courage
de le faire je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Pierre Jean verzelen
pour le groupe les indépendants pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois on fait le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
les évolutions récentes nous mettent
devant le fait accompli nous devons
réguler et encadrer de manière adaptée
et spécifique la reconnaissance
biométrique
cet outil qui permet d'identifier un
individu via un panel de
caractéristiques qui lui sont propres
l'intelligence artificielle connaît un
essor fulgurant notre rôle de
législateur prend tout son sens dans ce
domaine tout va très vite et nous avons
besoin d'un droit solide et protecteur
qui sera s'adapter au fur et à mesure
des évolutions c'est indispensable pour
protéger nos droits fondamentaux et nos
libertés individuelles dans notre pays
la reconnaissance biométrique est très
limitée et le droit n'est pas du tout
adapté
ce sujet revient souvent sur nos bancs
la mission d'information qui est à
l'origine de cette proposition de loi et
plus récemment lors du projet de loi sur
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
vouloir l'encadrer via un texte qui lui
est propre et nécessaire alors
inévitablement ce débat il fait penser à
celui qui a existé il y a quelques
années sur la vidéo surveillance
mais la reconnaissance biométrique elle
est là elle existe et elle peut être
utile pour améliorer la sécurité dans
l'espace public et lors de grands
événements pourquoi s'en priver
développons intelligemment ce nouvel
outil faisons-le de manière sécurisée
avec un modèle qui nous convient fixons
nous-mêmes les règles et les limites
qu'on souhaite s'imposer
c'est aussi un enjeu industriel majeur
le matériel et les logiciels devront
être français ou européens nous savons
que nous devons rester souverain la
matière c'est un enjeu pour tous les
citoyens français et européens
ça a été dit avant mais ce débat pose
également l'enjeu de la gestion des
données Google Facebook TikTok toutes
ces plateformes sont américaines ou
chinoises écartent à longueur de journée
des données sur nos populations et nous
peinons avoir émergé des outils
européens en la matière ne prenons pas
la même retard sur la reconnaissance
biométrique nous saluons la Commission
européenne qui s'est saisi de la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
avec Live Act je rejoins la vie du
rapporteur nous ne pouvons pas attendre
2025 que ce futur règlement européen
entre en application tout va très vite
beaucoup de nos voisins ont déjà recours
à la reconnaissance biométrique nous ne
sommes pas les États-Unis ou la pratique
est encadrée de manière plutôt vague
nous ne sommes certainement pas non plus
la Chine ou des millions de caméras
intelligentes sévissent chaque jour et
note les individus
cette proposition de loi est donc
essentielle elle nous interroge ensemble
sur le cadre que nous souhaitons
développer elle a le mérite d'ouvrir le
débat et si je puis dire de mettre le
pied dans la porte
nous saluons travailler effectuer en
commission des lois par le rapporteur
qui a renforcé les mécanismes
initialement proposés
l'article premier pose le cadre strict
des interdictions des différentes formes
d'identification à distance et sans
consentement des personnes physiques ou
encore un posteriori pour citer ces
quelques exemples
l'expérimentation sur une durée de trois
ans va dans le bon sens nous devons
évaluer ces mécanismes avant une
potentielle pérennisation
la subsidiarité qui a été introduite
dans les mécanismes et gage de
préservation des libertés la limitation
des expérimentations dans des cas très
précis et à caractère exceptionnel et
central ces mécanismes sont cruciaux
concernant la lutte contre le terrorisme
la criminalité organisée et les intérêts
de la nation
l'expérimentation prévue concernant les
grands événements sportifs et les
conditions de mise en œuvre sont des
pistes intéressantes pour l'avenir
trouver l'équilibre entre la sécurité
des Français et le respect de leur
liberté est une ligne de crête que nous
devons en permanence rechercher la
proposition de loi qui nous est proposée
est une première étape il y en aura à
mon avis bien d'autres nous sommes au
début du sujet le débat est lancé le
groupe Les Indépendants soutient les
grandes orientations de ce texte je vous
remercie de votre attention merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Thomas do su pour le groupe
écologiste pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
créer un cadre juridique expérimental
permettant par exception et de manière
strictement subsidiaire le recours ciblé
est limité dans le temps à des systèmes
de reconnaissance biométrique sur la
voie publique en temps réel sur la base
d'une menace préalablement identifiée et
à des fins de sécurisation de grands
événements ces mots ce sont ceux de
l'auteur de la proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui Monsieur Marc
Philippe daubrais à l'occasion de la loi
relative aux Jeux Olympiques durant
laquelle il définissait déjà les
contours du texte actuel puisque selon
lui la loi Jo n'allait pas assez loin
dans les innovations en matière de
surveillance notons les précautions les
circonsvolutions les périphrases
employées elles ne sont pas anodines et
résument en réalité les faux-semblants
qui sous-tendent ce texte que nous
étudions aujourd'hui en vérité le
procédé est toujours le même lorsqu'il
s'agit des technologies de fichage et de
surveillance de masse à une prudence
initiale suit la généralisation et la
fin des garde-fous
par exemple concernant les prélèvements
ADN ceci ont été introduits dans notre
droit en 1998 à la suite de l'affaire
Guy Georges et il concernait à l'époque
uniquement les condamnés définitifs pour
agression sexuelle 25 ans plus tard le
fichier national des empreintes
génétiques regroupent 3 millions de
personnes avec une écrasante majorité de
personnes non condamnées nous ne
comptons plus les prises d'empreintes
génétiques pour des participations à des
manifestations par exemple et le fait de
refuser de s'y soumettre et désormais un
délit passible d'un an de prison et de
15000 euros d'amende fichez l'ADN des
militants politiques nous nous sommes
accoutumés la vidéo surveillance a connu
le même essor avec un usage exponentiel
qui en a rendu l'usage massif avec
désormais depuis la loi Jo la
possibilité d'en laisser l'analyse à des
algorithmes encore une fois dans le
cadre d'une expérimentation qui sera
généralisée soyons en sûrs car oui à
chaque fois on commence par des
expérimentations des dispositifs réduits
des initiatives que l'on nous jure
strictement encadrés et qui aboutissent
invariablement à leur généralisation
peu liberté publique deviennent
secondaires pour les apprentis sociétaux
de la société de surveillance nous
sortons à peine d'une loi là aussi
d'exception pour légaliser la
surveillance algorithmique durant les
Jeux Olympiques que les fanatiques du
flicage nous proposent déjà d'aller plus
loin le risque quantités
à la surveillance globale qu'importe que
la reporter spécial sur la promotion et
la protection des droits de l'homme et
des libertés fondamentales dans la lutte
antiterroriste pour l'ONU est dénoncé
dans son rapport l'utilisation du
terrorisme comme justification politique
pour adapter les technologies à aux
risques qu'importe que la Défenseur des
droits souligne un risque inhérent
d'atteinte au roi au respect de la vie
privée et à la protection des données
qu'importe que le MIT révèle que des
technologies de surveillance
automatisées présentent des préjugés
liés au sexe ou à la couleur de peau
il nous faudrait innover dans la société
de contrôle toujours plus loin toujours
plus fort sans jamais réfléchir au
modèle de société que cela induit que
contient ce texte tout d'abord une forte
dose d'hypocrisie en effet son premier
article pose un cadre très fort
d'interdiction pour empêcher la
catégorisation la notation ou la
reconnaissance des personnes par les
technologies de biométrie le tout a
sorti d'un contrôle sérieux du Parlement
de la CNIL ou de la cnctr on aurait pu
s'arrêter là avec quelques sanctions
pour des usages illégaux mais que
contient le reste du texte une liste
d'exception à cette interdiction
générale la biométrie jamais sauf pour
contrôler l'accès aux grands événements
permettre l'exploitation d'image a
posteriori pour retrouver des auteurs ou
des victimes d'infraction surveiller des
foules en direct lors des événements dit
à risque
ou encore aider aux investigations de
services de renseignement dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme la liste est déjà
longue mais elle sera trop courte pour
un grand un pour un prochain
gouvernement qui pourra rajouter à
souhait des exceptions supplémentaires à
partir du moment où vous acceptez avec
ce texte la dissémination la
prolifération de ces technologies alors
vous devrez en assumer l'usage qui
deviendra générale n'en doutez pas ce
texte est un cadeau de bienvenue à un
prochain gouvernement plus autoritaire
puisqu'il n'aura qu'à pérenniser l'usage
de la biométrie en rallongeant la liste
des usages possibles celles et ceux qui
sont attachés à la devise républicaine
notamment le premier terme gravé au
fronton de nos mairies celui de liberté
devrait être horrifié par ce texte les
garde-fous ni changeront rien
l'autorisation même partielle de ces
technologies ne fera qu'en multiplier le
développement leur usage et la société
de surveillance mettra à mal notre
démocratie l'usage politique de cette
technologie ne sera pas entravée par les
garde-fous les dérives politiques de la
surveillance policière sont déjà très
concrètes la lettre A se faisait encore
l'écho la semaine dernière d'un bras de
fer entre Matignon et Beauvau quant à la
surveillance et la mise sur écoute de
militants écologiste nous le savons
également l'enjeu n'est pas que sécurité
il est aussi économique beaucoup appel
et ses ambitions ont été énoncées très
clairement durant les débats sur la
locmi à promouvoir soutenir et
développer les champions français de la
techno sécurité au nom des de la défense
des libertés publiques nous refaisons le
projet société que vous défendez avec ce
texte une société du fichage de
l'abolition du privé de l'intime un
continuum de sécurité qui considère tout
comme une donnée à traiter jusqu'au
phénotypes même des individus un
carquant indépassable qui n'a qu'une
visée le contrôle partout tout le temps
c'est pourquoi nous proposons la plus la
suppression de la plupart des articles
et nous votre compte ce texte merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
madame Nicole Duranton pour le groupe
RDPI pour 6 minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues comme l'ont
indiqué les précédentes orateurs nous
sommes aujourd'hui à mener à nous
prononcer sur une proposition de loi de
nos collègues Marc Philippe daubrais et
Arnaud de Bella
reconnaissance biométrique dans l'espace
public
issus des propositions formulées par une
mission d'information de la commission
des lois ce texte nous propose d'une
part de fixer des lignes rouges pour
faire obstacle à une société de
surveillance d'autre part d'expérimenter
de nouveaux cas d'usage de cette
technologie qui croit exponentiellement
grâce aux algorithmes d'apprentissage
nous le savons l'opinion publique est
polarisée entre ceux qui craignent
l'usage poussé des technologies
biométriques en raison de leur nature
attentatoire aux libertés et ceux qui
soulignent davantage ces bénéfices
potentiels pour la sécurité de tous la
reconnaissance biométrique dans l'espace
public n'est effectivement pas un outil
anodin elle fait partie de ces outils
qui relèvent d'un choix de société et
qui requier donc une attention et une
évaluation toute particulière en effet
ces applications possibles sont
illimitées elles peuvent dépasser le
seul prisme sécurité pour rythmer un
simple acte de la vie courante ou une
activité commerciale dès lors permettre
l'usage de telles technologies sans
instaurer de garde-fou et dangereuses
des exemples de là de nos frontières
nous montre comment cet usage comporte
une part de risques notamment lorsqu'il
est utilisé par un régime totalitaire
contre ses propres concitoyens nous
avons tous en tête l'exemple de la Chine
ou la reconnaissance faciale rythme le
moindre acte de la vie quotidienne
obtenir une ligne de téléphone portable
faciliter l'enregistrement dans un hôtel
identifier des élèves qui sachent les
cours ou la reconnaissance faciale est
devenue une arme politique par exemple à
Hong Kong ou la région sing Chang contre
la minorité ouigo pour en revenir au
texte si nous souscrivons à l'ambition
de fixer des lignes rouges en revanche
l'ouverture d'expérimentation de
nouveaux cas d'usage nous alertes à cet
égard l'analyse des services de la CNIL
qui a été présenté à la commission des
lois par son secrétaire général Louis du
teillay de Lamotte est aussi éclairante
qu'alarmante selon ce dernier alors que
l'expérimentation des technologies
biométriques ne devraient être réalisées
qu'avec une extrême prudence et de
manière progressive la proposition de
loi que nous examinons élargi de manière
considérable et d'un seul coup les cas
d'usage comme il le rappelle choisir
d'expérimenter c'est déjà choisir de
créer contrairement aux recommandations
des services de la CNIL la commission
des lois a fait le choix de maintenir
les dispositions relatives à la
reconnaissance biométrique en temps réel
nous ne pouvons que le regretter
vivement selon Monsieur duthier De
Lamotte l'identification en temps réel
dans l'espace public à titre
expérimental
remarquerez une rupture fondamentale
pour l'exercice de nos libertés
publiques alors que nous n'avons pas
encore de recul sur l'efficacité et
l'utilité de la biométrie dans les
autres cas d'usage sans compter les
risques
identifier d'erreurs d'identification
les billets discriminatoires les risques
d'inhibition dans l'exercice des droits
des libertés fondamentales ou encore le
risque de sécurité informatique par
conséquent avant d'étudier la
possibilité de recourir à cette
technologie nous estimons qu'il est
préférable de prendre le temps de tester
l'emploi des caméras augmenter sans
reconnaissance faciale dont
l'expérimentation est prévue par
l'article 10 de la très récente loi du
19 mai 2023 relative aux Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de 2024 et portant
diverses autres dispositions attendre
donc de pouvoir faire le bilan de cette
expérimentation qui se déroulera au
cours des Jeux Olympiques et
paralympiques à partir de du 26 juillet
2024 avant d'aller plus loin quant au
développement de la reconnaissance
faciale pour toutes ces raisons que je
viens dénoncer et parce qu'il nous faut
légiférer avec une prudence accrue en la
matière le groupe RDPI votera contre ce
texte je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Jérôme Durin pour le groupe
socialiste pour 9 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur
nous voici réunis pour un examen dans
une niche un lundi au soleil allez je
dire pour un sujet qui mériterait sans
doute davantage d'être braqué sous les
projecteurs médiatiques un mardi sous la
pluie peut-être monsieur
l'intelligence artificielle et son
application dans les images animées ou
pas ont suscité quelques débats ces
derniers mois dans le sillage du succès
de giacjibity et des débats sur la
vidéoprojection algorithmique examinée
dans le cadre du projet de loi Jeux
Olympiques je crains cependant que le
format de notre discussion de cet
après-midi ne nous permettent pas de
rencontrer le même succès cela est
compréhensible nous ne sommes et je dis
ça avec tout le respect que j'ai pour
l'initiative parlementaire nous sommes
que dans une niche nous ne disposons
nous ne disposons pas d'études d'impact
et la vie de Madame la Ministre démontre
que ce texte n'est pas porté à bras le
corps par le gouvernement et puis
surtout il y a l'agenda d'examen notre
débat peut sembler confus à l'extérieur
de cette hémicycle parce qu'il
intervient quelques semaines seulement
après la promulgation du projet de loi
sur les jeux olympiques que j'ai déjà
évoqué il y a quelques semaines nous
avons été nombreux
et je m'inclus dans ce nou à débattre
des mesures concernant la
vidéoprotection algorithmique sur les
Jeux Olympiques et à répéter souvent
avec sincérité non il n'y aura pas de
reconnaissance faciale aux JO cela a été
dit avec sincérité pour plusieurs
raisons nous avons été nombreux à penser
qu'il était trop tôt que les réticences
exprimées dans la société autour de
l'utilisation des algorithmes sans
données biométriques créés suffisamment
réticence pour éviter d'aller encore
plus loin avec la reconnaissance faciale
de manière plus pragmatique de nombreux
acteurs nous disent qu'il est trop tard
que mettre en place les systèmes de
reconnaissance faciale prend du temps et
que rien ne serait de toute façon
opérationnelle pour les Jeux Olympiques
je pense que ces messages que nous avons
pour beaucoup nous-mêmes répétés ont été
entendus permettez-moi de rappeler
quelques-uns j'ouvre les guillemets nous
nous félicitons de ce que la ligne rouge
alors que les sens faciale n'est pas été
franchie dans le projet de loi déposé
par le Gouvernement déclarait la
rapporteur de la commission des lois sur
le récent projette de loi Jeux
Olympiques
j'ouvre les guillemets à nouveau je suis
opposé à la reconnaissance faciale
déclarait Gérald Darmanin en audition
devant notre commission nous ne voulons
pas de la reconnaissance faciale ni de
l'utilisation de données et de systèmes
d'identification biométrique pour ces
jeux non seulement ces procédés ne nous
semblent pas nécessaire sur le plan
opérationnel mais surtout les autres
dispositifs prévus permettront à eux
seuls un saut qualitatif en matière de
prévention et de lutte contre les
troubles à l'ordre public déclarait
madame oudea Castéra l'Assemblée
nationale alors j'ai bien compris que
certaines de ces citations étaient
soumises à interprétation voire à une
date limite de validité je comprends ces
subtilités après tout j'ai moi-même
signé le rapport de notre commission des
lois sur leur connaissance faciale avant
de refuser de signer la proposition de
loi qui ont découlé par la suite mettez
moi cependant de vous expliquer mon
raisonnement personnel avant de vous
confier la position de mon groupe sur
cette proposition de loi je ne crois pas
que la reconnaissance faciale telle que
les perçue par les auteurs du texte donc
je connais par ailleurs les intentions
la qualité du travail et les une
précautions qu'ils ont témoignés pendant
ce travail comme par le rapporteur
constitue un danger en soi c'est une
technologie qui commence à être efficace
même si elle conserve quelques
faiblesses elle est déjà utilisée par
nos citoyens dans certains de leurs
actes quotidiens je pense au
déverrouillage des téléphones par
exemple l'encadrer semble très important
et on peut d'ailleurs noter qu'un cadre
global sur l'IA va bientôt nous être
donné par l'Union européenne si on prend
en considération le succès du rgpd on
peut d'ailleurs imaginer que l'échelon
européen est le plus adapté à la
régulation du numérique la position du
rapporteur est de dire que cela viendra
trop tardivement je pense au contraire
qu'il ne sert à rien de se précipiter
sur un sujet éthique qui aura des
conséquences sur plusieurs décennies je
considère que ce sujet mériterait un
débat national d'envergure
oserais-je dire une convention citoyenne
je ne crois pas que nous compatriotes
soient par nature ni opposant ni
partisans de cette technologie et je ne
préjuge pas des conclusions qui
pourraient en sortir je suis un fervent
défenseur de la démocratie parlementaire
mais je crois que sur certains sujets au
l'accepterabilité est essentiel il
importe de mettre en place des processus
de décision qui associent le plus de
citoyens possibles pour le dire
autrement je ne crois pas que cela passe
par un projet de loi ou par une
proposition ordinaire vous l'aurez
compris ce sont l'ensemble de ces
arguments qui conduisent aujourd'hui mon
groupe à l'adoption à ce moment du débat
public à s'opposer à l'adoption à ce
moment du débat public de cette
proposition de loi la réécriture de
Monsieur bas a des vertus la volonté
d'encadrer cette technologie est louable
mais nous croyons que l'heure n'est pas
venu par ailleurs en matière
technologique l'effet cliquet n'est
jamais loin une ratrice avant moi a cité
l'audition du secrétaire général de la
CNIL aujourd'hui nous repoussons le
modèle chinois de reconnaissance faciale
comme nous repoussions hier l'Internet à
la chinoise protégé derrière son grand
firewall et pourtant aujourd'hui de plus
en plus de voix jalousent les
possibilités offertes par l'Internet
chinois pour protéger les mineurs ou
censurer des contenus dangereux et
certains chers collègues que le modèle
chinois de reconnaissance faciale sera
toujours repoussoir dans 10 ans votre
réponse est-elle dépendante des
changements de majorités politiques que
pourrait connaître ce pays vous hésitez
peut-être sur votre réponse c'est ce qui
détermine nos réflexions je voudrais
ajouter qu'il faut se méfier du
solutionnisme technologique pouvoir pour
avoir des battu de l'utilité de cette
technologie avec des dizaines de
personnes ces dernières années je
retiens quelques limites qui nous
permettront de relativiser l'urgence de
notre débat premièrement la
reconnaissance faciale n'est pas une
recette miracle oui elle sera utile dans
certains cas enlèvement de personnes
menace terroriste identifiées et
j'insiste sur
identifier recherche de personnes
dangereuses précises elle ne fera pas
disparaître l'ensemble de ces menaces
oui elle sera utile dans la résolution
d'enquête mais il faut garder l'esprit
que la vidéoprotection elle-même n'a pas
fait disparaître la criminalité dans
notre pays même si elle est utile elle a
ses limites et la Cour des comptes ne
s'est pas privée de le rappeler de
multiples reprises la vidéoprotection et
la reconnaissance faciale ne vont pas
sans intervention humaine dans des
exemples tristement dramatiques certains
encore très récents se sont bien des
interventions humaines qui ont permis de
mettre fin au drame qui se déroulait
aucune caméra avec ou sans connaissance
faciale on aurait pu empêcher ce qui
s'est passé un acteur du renseignement
me disait c'est un peu trivial mais
c'est très réel ce n'est pas parce que
j'identifie celui qui a rayé ma voiture
sur le parking que ma voiture est
réparée il fallait
commenter cette exemple concret il n'y
aura pas de miracle sauf
exceptionnellement et ces technologies
vont pourtant nous coûter très cher un
autre expert me disait vous avez aimé
les milliards dépensés pour la vidéo
prospection vous allez adorer le coût de
la reconnaissance faciale
cette expert disait par ailleurs que
pour reprendre les propos de la ministre
l'adéquation d'utilité de la
reconnaissance faciale avec une doctrine
sécuritaire plus large et déterminante
et le coût de cette technologie est loin
d'être anodin par rapport aux autres
moyens mis en oeuvre et évidemment il
reviendra à l'État au ministre de
l'Intérieur un gouvernement d'articuler
cet ensemble de solutions
mes chers collègues le texte qui est
soumis à notre sagacité aujourd'hui
n'est pas selon moi un mauvais texte
l'initiative de messieurs dobresse et de
Bernay assez vertus les enrichissements
apportés par le rapporteur bas sont
indéniable mais nous considérons au
groupe socialiste que ce débat qui
intervient après que nous ayons tous
répété urbi et orbi que la
reconnaissance faciale ne serait pas en
place aux JO et prématuré face au
bouleversement d'intelligence
artificielle croisée avec les données
biométriques il me semble il nous semble
prudent d'avancer conjointement avec
l'Europe vous comprendrez donc sûrement
vous le regretterez peut-être que nous
ne soutiendrons pas ce texte
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame la Présidente Eliane
assassy pour le groupe CRCE pour 5
minutes
vous avez la parole madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues Sylla pratique de la
surveillance des populations par l'État
est ancienne sa massification ça
sophistication et sa banalisation
interroge fichage massif de nos
concitoyens des organisations syndicales
des syndicats liste et des militants
déploiement incontrôlés de la vidéo
surveillance qu'elle soit traditionnelle
ou algorithmique
usage de drones marquage des
manifestants activation à distance et
téléphone portable dans un but de
géolocalisation mais aussi activation à
distance de la caméra et du micro de ces
appareils scanner corporel la panoplie
des mesures de surveillance sous couvert
de justification sécuritaire se
multiplient de manière inquiétante pour
ne pas dire glaçante tout cela dans
l'apathie générale ce qui hier au levé
de la dystopie se concrétise pas à pas
sous nos yeux sans aucun débat public
pire sous couvert d'écarter le risque
d'une société de surveillance le texte
dont nous débattons aujourd'hui instaure
le principe d'une telle surveillance en
se cachant derrière l'impératif de
préserver nos intérêts économiques en
développant des outils techniques
français qui améliorent la sécurité
s'ennuie au Liberté et les Jeux
olympiques ou autre mégas événements
sont autant de chevaux de Troie pour
faire progresser des politiques qu'il
aurait été difficile voir impossible de
mettre en place en temps normal comme le
rappeler très justement de nombreuses
ONG et c'est ainsi que ce texte propose
sous couvert d'expérimentation dans une
logique de prévention de des risques de
lutte contre des menaces supposées ou
avérées ou d'efficacité des enquêtes de
banaliser la vidéo surveillance
automatisée une surveillance massive de
l'espace public pour détecter des
comportements soi-disant anormaux via
l'identification par reconnaissance
faciale en temps réel et comme pour
d'autres systèmes de surveillance par le
passé tout en reconnaissant le caractère
intrusif des technologies biométriques
arguments avancé pour les mettre en
place et l'impossibilité je cite de se
priver de la reconnaissance faciale dans
des cas particulièrement graves afin de
garantir la sécurité de nos concitoyens
à condition que son déploiement
exceptionnel soit entouré de garanties
nécessaires fin de citation alors selon
monsieur le rapporteur il ne fallait pas
je cite nous attarder sur les dangers
réels de cette technologie en matière
d'atteinte à la vie privée sur les
risques de développement d'une société
de surveillance à la chinoise ou encore
sur des erreurs possibles
d'identification car cette technologie
présente des avantages dont il serait
dommage de se priver définitivement elle
permet notamment de prévenir des
attentats ou encore de retrouver des
criminels fin des sites de citations
notons ici
que cette technologie
est aussi source quand même de revenir
juteux pour de nombreux acteurs privés
nous parlons quand même d'un marché en
pleine extension expansion pardon qui
pèsera pour près de 76 milliards de
dollars dans le monde à l'horizon 2025
pour notre part c'est au contraire sur
le risque de ces technologies de et de
la société que nous voulons doit-il faut
débattre avant tout car nous savons que
ces dispositifs comportent des risques
de discrimination d'erreurs d'atteintes
aux libertés fondamentales et nous
pouvons les balayer et nous ne pouvons
les balayer d'un revers demain ce que
c'est ce que nous confirme la CNIL en
pointant le fait que je cite les bases
de données utilisées pour le calibrage
des algorithmes les femmes les gens de
couleur les personnes différentes sont
moins bien identifiées par des
intelligences artificielles faisant
peser le risque de leur occasionner plus
de contrôle moins de liberté de plus
comme le souligne la Quadrature du Net
je cite les comportements dit suspects
ne sont que la matérialisation de choix
politique subjectif et discriminatoire
qui se focalise sur les personnes
passant le plus de temps dans la rue
qu'elles soient humaines ou
algorithmique l'interprétation des
images est toujours dictée par des
critères sociaux et moraux et l'ajout
d'une couche logicielle n'y change rien
enfin ne nous y trompons pas ces 10
dernières années toutes les mesures
d'exception expérimentales ont fini
d'une manière ou d'une autre par entrer
dans le droit commun et s'étendre à
l'ensemble de la population à toutes les
situations depuis près de 20 ans avec
une accélération certaine ces dernières
années nous sommes enfermés dans des
politiques sécuritaires dont
l'efficacité n'a pas été prouvé les
outils de surveillance se renforcent et
les lois se durcissent sans aucun débat
public je reprends ici les mots de
Madame Mireille Delmas Marty qui il y a
plusieurs années s'interroger sur l'état
autoritaire à l'écrivait je cite l'état
autoritaire n'est pas nouveau ce qui est
nouveau peut-être c'est sa façon d'être
autor itaire d'une autorité grise et
pénétrante qui chaque repli de la vie
autorité indolore et invisible et
pourtant confusément accepté
effectivement ne laissons pas l'exigence
de sécurité brisée le rêve de la liberté
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Gilbert Favreau pour
le groupe les républicains pour 7
minutes
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le Raptor porteur
chers collègues
le philosophe grec et ZOP a dit il y a
maintenant à peu près 26 siècles la
langue et la meilleure ou la pire des
choses cette citation peut s'appliquer à
la technique d'authentification
biométrique qui peut être un outil
précieux pour identifier une personne
recherchée mais qui peut de la même
façon servir la politique de répression
d'un régime totalitaire
son usage fait la une de l'actualité à
quelques mois de la Coupe du monde de
rugby en septembre prochain et des Jeux
Olympiques en juillet 2024 ne faut-il
pas avoir peur de cette technologie
potentiellement redoutable rappelez-vous
le 16 avril dernier
la République islamique d'Iran a annoncé
la mise en place d'une politique
répressive pour lutter contre le
non-port des voiles du voile par les
femmes pour arriver à ses fins le régime
des Molas a annoncé l'introduction du
système de reconnaissance faciale pour
traquer ses femmes militantes de la
liberté en Chine populaire dans un pays
qui maîtrise parfaitement cette
technologie la reconnaissance faciale a
été généralisée au point que les
autorités sont en mesure d'identifier
dans chaque rue un individu de connaître
par exemple le sol de son solde bancaire
de procéder à la filature et à
l'arrestation de celui ou de celle qui
n'a pas payé son reliquat d'impôts ou
qui n'a pas payé une amende prise dans
le train ou dans le métro
plus récemment encore est apparu un
programme informatique américain chat
GPT qui va sans doute bouleverser notre
rapport à la compétence c'est dans ce
contexte que lors de l'examen au Sénat
en janvier dernier du projet de loi
relatif à l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques de Paris la question de la
reconnaissance biométrique s'est posée à
la représentation nationale en effet
2024 sera une année où la France va
accueillir des sportifs et supportèrent
du monde entier et il serait terrible
pour notre image que la menace
terroriste ou la criminalité organisée
Vienne ternir cette période
cela nous a permis de prendre conscience
du vide juridique sur ce sujet en droit
français il était donc urgent de
légiférer et cette proposition de loi
vient donner un cadre légal à l'usage de
cette pratique pour cela je remercie
vivement mes collègues Marc philippe
daubrais Arnaud de belnay et Bruno
Retailleau de nous présenter ce texte
aujourd'hui
un rapport d'information publié le 30
mars 2023 par 4 sénateurs de la
commission des affaires européennes du
Sénat a pour autant qualifié de
pratiques à haut risque la mise en place
de la reconnaissance biométrique dans
l'espace public invitant le législateur
à l'interdire totalement sauf raison
très exceptionnelle
le texte qui vient aujourd'hui devant le
Sénat tient compte de toutes ces
préoccupations sur le fond il précise
dès son articles premiers que la
reconnaissance biométrique est limitée
par plusieurs lignes rouges interdisant
formellement la catégorisation la
notation et la reconnaissance
biométrique des personnes physiques dans
l'espace public
je salue également le travail de la
commission des lois de son rapporteur
Philippe Bas que je salue qui a ajouté
l'interdiction d'identification a
postériori dans l'espace public ces
interdictions posent les bases d'une
garantie de maintien des libertés
empêchant notre pays de sombrer dans une
société de surveillance généralisée cela
étant il est nécessaire de pouvoir se
doter de tous les moyens que la
technologie nous offre pour protéger les
Français des attaques terroristes ou de
la criminalité grandissante ainsi il est
proposé dans ce texte
d'expérimenter pour trois ans un système
de reconnaissance de reconnaissance
biométrique les différentes exceptions
au principe d'interdiction serait
obligatoirement autorisée par la loi et
l'application réglementaire se ferait
après avis de la Commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés ou de la
Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement en ce qui
concerne l'utilisation d'images en temps
réel
cette pratique serait limitée aux
actions antiterroristes afin d'éviter
une attaque sur des civils innocents
ainsi à titre expérimental les services
du Premier Cercle des GSI Tracfin
pourront utiliser la reconnaissance
faciale sur la voie publique lorsqu'une
action concernera la défense nationale
la prévention d'un état d'un attentat
terroriste etc en ce qui concerne
l'utilisation d'image pour des enquêtes
judiciaires cela ne pourra se faire
qu'après autorisation de l'autorité
judiciaire pour lutter contre la grande
criminalité ou rechercher des fugitifs
ou des victimes dans l'élèvement enfin
pour des événements particuliers et
ayant lieu sur la voie publique comme
les Jeux Olympiques par exemple ce
système pourrait être mis en place dans
des actions de police administrative
donc préventive lorsqu'une menace grave
plânera sur l'événement ainsi sans
entrer dans tous les détails juridiques
de la proposition de loi ce texte arrive
à point nommé et me semble être un bon
équilibre entre la nécessaire garantie
des droits fondamentaux d'une démocratie
comme la France et le défi d'une
protection efficace de nos concitoyens
ce texte je l'espère servira de vase et
l'exemple pour nos homologues européens
en matière d'utilisation de la
reconnaissance biométrique il était donc
logique dans ces conditions que sur le
rapport de notre collègue Philippe Bas
et lors de l'examen du texte la
commission des lois tiennent compte des
craintes exprimées sur les dangers
potentiels de la mise en oeuvre d'une
telle technologie dans l'espace public
le texte issu des discussions en
commission et qui va être soumis au vote
du Sénat exprime de façon très
didactique la prise en compte des
interrogations légitimes de certains
élus sur les possibles dérives de la
reconnaissance biométrique dans l'espace
public et organise à l'opposé à un
dispos itif légal qui sera garant de la
sécurité des citoyens et des libertés
publiques il a d'ailleurs été ça a été
souligné tout à l'heure approuvé à
l'unanimité par la commission des lois
et je m'en félicité c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voterai ce texte je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close nous passons à la
discussion du texte de la commission
avec à l'article premier un amendement 2
monsieur dessus
merci monsieur le Président parce
qu'elle cible le plus souvent les
caractéristiques des individus qui les
exposent à des discriminations les
technologies biométriques et la
généralisation de leur usage sont
susceptibles d'amplifier pour certains
groupes sociaux les discriminations
systémiques opérant au sein de notre
société en d'autres termes ces
technologies sont biaisées oui
lorsqu'elles sont déployées ces
technologies cibles en priorité les
personnes pauvres car la surveillance
est basée sur des critères sociaux en
visant prioritairement les personnes qui
se trouvent souvent à la rue par manque
de ressources en plus des risques d'abus
policiers c'est biais contribuent aussi
à générer un contrôle aux faciès
automatisées nous demandons donc ici
clairement d'interdire la catégorisation
et la notation d'individus sur la base
de leurs origines ethniques de leur
orientation sexuelle de leur sexe de
leur comportement social ou de certaines
de leurs conviction ainsi que l'analyse
d'émotions soit interdite
avis de la commission sur le rapporteur
ce président la vie de la Commission et
défavorable il s'agit pas quand on parle
de religion ou de sexe de donner
biométriques il est donc pas
utile de préciser que les données
biométriques ne doivent pas donner
d'informations sur ces caractéristiques
du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président mais ma vie
que la Commission sur le fondement que
seuls les données qui permet
d'identifier de manière unique un
individu son biométrique ce sont des
empreintes digitales l'ADN des
photographies la reconnaissance des
émotions ne repose pas sur des données
biométriques aucune des informations que
vous listez ne permet d'identifier de
manière unique une personne avis du
gouvernement défavorable merci je mets
aux voiles amendement 2 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
le premier qui est pour
quiconque
adopter
à l'article premier bis un amendement de
3 Monsieur dossu Merci monsieur le
Président nous considérons et nous ne
sommes pas les seuls que chaque
expérimentation chaque renforcement de
nos politiques sécurité par la
technologie se fait sans retour en
arrière bien au contraire les usages et
les autorisations ont même plutôt
parfois tendance à s'étendre cela a été
le cas notamment je l'ai dit lors de la
discussion générale sur les prélèvements
ADN si au début on nous jurait que
l'usage serait circonscrit aux actes de
terrorisme force de constater que son
usage c'est largement répandu ainsi
qu'en janvier de cette année à
manifestant contre les réformes contre
la réforme des retraites et passant plus
parution immédiate pour avoir refusé de
donner ses empreintes génétiques lors de
son arrestation qui peut s'habituer à ce
confiche l'ADN des militants politiques
ou syndicaux qu'est-ce qui nous garantit
que la surveillance biométrique ne
suivra pas ce chemin rien et
certainement pas l'expérience que nous
avons
des évolutions législatives analogues
c'est pourquoi nous vous souhaitons
inscrire en toute lettre que la
pérennisation ne va pas de soi que le
débat sur cette technologie a besoin de
contradictoires
monsieur le rapporteur même de
l'expérimentation que la pérennisation
n'aille pas de soi Monsieur le Président
mais si c'est abondement ne fait pas de
bien et ne fait pas de mal non plus et
la Commission a donc décidé de lui
donner un avis favorable pour rassurer
ces auteurs
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président il va de soi
que lorsque le législateur autorise une
expérimentation monsieur le sénateur il
ne préjugue pas de sa pérennisation
puisqu'une intervention législative et
par construction indispensable pour la
pérenniser j'en profite pour rappeler
que nous avons déjà eu ce débats
l'occasion des discussions autour du
projet de loi de Jo il ne pourra pas
davantage y avoir pérennisation par
principe et le dernier mot reviendra au
Parlement votre amendement est donc
satisfait je vous invite à bien vouloir
le rejeter je vous remercie madame de La
Grande truie
merci monsieur le Président je crois que
c'est un amendement plus important qu'il
en a l'air et que c'est un message
peut-être un peu appuyé en direction du
gouvernement nous ne cessons je suis
parlementaire de maintenant depuis
quelques années n'empêche que nous ne
cessons de voir des textes qui instaure
des expérimentations qui ne font pas
l'objet d'évaluation même lorsqu'elles
sont prévues et qui ensuite périnissent
alors on a pu le voir dans des moments
qui étaient un peu particuliers comme la
crise covid mais on le voit en tout cas
moi je siège à la commission des lois on
le voit régulièrement sur tout un tas de
sujets donc le rapporteur a parlé
sagement comme la coutumée c'est vrai
que strictosensus ça ne devrait pas être
nécessaire de le dire sauf que
l'expérience montre que c'est toujours
nécessaire donc nous sommes favorables à
cet amendement
très bien je vais mettre voilà
l'amendement 3 avec un avis favorable de
la commission un avis plus réservé on va
dire comme ça du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté je mets donc
voilà l'article premier bis ainsi
modifier qui est pour
quiconque il est adopté à l'article
premier de terre un amendement un
rectifié bis madame chalk
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit de
réintroduire dans la loi un principe de
transparence relatif au développement
des logiciels de traitement en effet il
faut regretter que des garanties
relatives à leur développement et à
l'organisation du traitement des données
biométriques prévues dans la version
initiale de cette proposition de loi et
était supprimée au profit d'un simple
renvoi à décret en Conseil d'État
pourtant le législateur ne saurait
consentir à cet abandon de compétences
au profit du pouvoir réglementaire par
ailleurs susceptible de
surconstitutionnel l'intervention du
législateur est nécessaire dans ce
domaine car la reconnaissance
biométrique résulte d'indissociables
aspects immatériel et matériel cette
abandon de compétences serait d'autant
plus dommageable que des exigences
européennes seront directement
applicables sans que le législateur
français ne se saisisse de ce sujet et
ne fixent ses propres garanties de
manière concrète enfin il est nécessaire
d'aider les autorités administratives
compétentes dans l'exercice de leur
pouvoir de contrôle déontologique le
présent amendement prévoit donc la
faculté de saisir pour avis et à titre
subsidiaire la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique voici
les différents motifs de l'amendement
qui a été déposé par mon collègue André
Richard merci monsieur le rapporteur la
commission a émis un avis de sagesse et
en ce qui me concerne je voterai cet
amendement
oui nous trouvons que cet amendement est
particulièrement important dans le
travail que nous avons effectué avec les
collègues on a pu observer que les
conditions de développement des outils
algorithmiques que ce soit l'origine des
données ou la nature des opérateurs
était essentiels et donc qu'on puisse
attester de
leur
pedigree de leur passé professionnel et
des intentions qu'il déploient dans les
activités qui souhaitent exercer pour
l'État nous paraît très important merci
je mets aux voix l'amendement un avec
deux avis de sagesse qui pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient
c'était la sagesse mais bon
adopter trois amendements de discussion
commune peut-être monsieur dossu comme
vous êtes l'auteur des trois ils sont en
discussion commune présentait les trois
merci monsieur le Président merci donc
la maman numéro 4 donc le dernier alinéa
de l'article 1ère introduit en
commission par notre rapporteur prévoit
qu'un échantillon d'image collecté au
moyen de caméra dédiées puisse être
utilisé comme donnée d'apprentissage
pendant une durée de 4 mois à compter de
l'enregistrement des images il est
parieur prévu dans cette alinéa que ces
images soient détruites au bout de trois
ans après la promulgation de la loi
traiter ce sujet est sensible des
algorithmes pour pouvoir correctement
fonctionner ont besoin de donner
d'apprentissage en l'espèce pour la
biométrie ils ont besoin de voir
d'analyser des personnes afin de
s'entraîner ce seront donc des personnes
présentes dans l'espace public qui
seront sans leur consentement des
cobayes pour cet apprentissage pour nous
cela n'est pas acceptable les libertés
publiques n'ont pas à être un terrain
d'entraînement ou d'expérimentation
par ailleurs le texte prévoit que des
entreprises privées puissent être
chargées de développer des traitements
biométriques cela signifie que leur
activité et leur revenu seraient donc
assurés par des personnes non
consentantes dans l'espace public et
donc même si c'est des garde-fous ont
été érigés même si la destruction des
données est prévue il y a là un
glissement démocratique peu acceptable
et donc c'est alinéa avec les dangers et
les dérives qu'il contient est à
l'opposé des convictions de des auteurs
de cet abandon c'est pourquoi nous
proposons de le supprimer
je vais continuer avec l'amendement
numéro 12 la ligne à 10 de l'article
premier prétend améliorer la performance
des traitements de données biométriques
mais de quelle performance de quelle
amélioration parle-t-on exactement
d'après la CNIL les technologies
biométriques nuisent à la possibilité
protégée par le droit d'aller venir sans
être reconnu avec une forme d'anonymat
elle comporte un risque d'erreur
important qui entraîne l'arrestation de
personnes non recherchées par fois ces
technologies comporte également des
biais discriminatoires majeurs une étude
du MIT révèle que les technologies
d'intelligence artificielle présente des
préjugés aux gens ou au type de la
couleur de peau en analysant un logiciel
de reconnaissance faciale les chercheurs
ont découvert un taux d'erreur de 0,8%
pour des hommes à la peau claire et de
34,7 pour des femmes à la peau foncée
par ailleurs comme je l'ai déjà expliqué
cette expression que des entreprises
privées puissent être chargées de
développer les traitements biométriques
une aubaine pour ces entreprises puisque
le marché de la vidéo surveillance
automatisé en 2020 au niveau mondial
représente plus de 11 milliards de
dollars
nous ne voulons certainement pas rendre
ces technologies plus performantes et
permettre aux entreprises de s'enrichir
en exploitant la vie privée de personnes
c'est pour cette raison que nous
proposons au contraire de remplacer le
dispositif d'amélioration en trompe
l'oeil par un alinéa indiquant que les
critères sur lesquels se base ces
traitements biométriques devront être
disponibles en open source et que les
données utilisées dans le cadre de ce
traitement ne pourront être cédés ou
vendus
et le dernier
l'amendement numéro 5 comme je n'ai eu
de 16 de le rappeler dans cette
hémicycle les technologies biométriques
comportent des risques unanimement
dénoncés par les autorités indépendantes
comme la Défenseur des droits ou l'acnil
et donc selon le rapport 2021 du
Défenseur des droits sur les
technologies biométriques l'utilisation
de la reconnaissance biométrique
comporte je cite un risque inhérent
d'atteinte au droit et au respect de la
vie privée et à la protection des
données et peut générer des
discriminations voire les amplifier pour
la Cnil la reconnaissance biométrique
est particulièrement intrusive et
comporte un certain nombre de risques
pour les pour la protection des données
et de la vie privée face à ces risques
indéniables dans la vie privée des
personnes nous proposons un minima de
renforcer les garanties pour les
enregistrements utilisés à des fins
pédagogiques en assurant l'anonymat des
personnes figurant dans ces échantillons
merci monsieur le rapporteur sur ces
trois amendements
monsieur le Président la vie sera
défavorable sur le premier puisqu'il
prévoit la suppression de la collecte
d'un échantillon permettant d'améliorer
la maîtrise de la technologie de la
reconnaissance faciale il faut dire que
si on ne fiabélise pas les traitements
par l'expérimentation alors les risques
d'erreurs qu'il s'agit justement
d'éviter seront
maintenus au lieu de d'être réduit
l'amendement numéro 12 est assez voisin
de l'amendement numéro 4 il va en
réalité contre l'objectif de protection
affichée puisque
il postule que les traitements
biométriques pourraient être
réutilisable alors que précisément notre
texte veut éviter qu'il le soit et enfin
s'agissante de l'amendement numéro 5
il
prévoit que avant d'utiliser les données
issues de traitement biométrique par
reconnaissance faciale
pour des formations il faudrait
anonymiser les images recueillies mais
précisément notre texte interdit
d'utiliser ces données pour à des fins
de formation du coup nous n'avons pas à
prévoir l'anonymisation en cas de
formation puisque nous ne voulons pas
faire de formation donc nous sommes plus
restrictifs que ce que semble postuler
cet amendement numéro 5 d'où la vie
défavorable merci madame la ministre
président donc sur l'amendement 4 donc
comme on a pu l'indiquer tout à l'heure
monsieur le sénateur dessus le
gouvernement est assez circonspect sur
l'opportunité de cette proposition de
loi aujourd'hui sur le fond
je ne suis pas convaincu que cette
rédaction de l'article 10 de loi Jeux
Olympiques conçus pour la détection
d'événements génériques et modalisables
soient parfaitement transposable à la
reconnaissance faciale et mériterait
d'être examinée plus avant en lien aussi
avec les experts de cette technologie
donc nous émettons aussi un avis
défavorable pour la mandement 12 rendre
public des cotes sources des outils des
forces de sécurité intérieure est
incompatible avec l'exigence de sécurité
la confidentialité de leur
fonctionnement technique et la condition
sinequanone de leur efficacité à défaut
les délinquants et criminels s'en
serviront à l'insu des forces de
sécurité intérieure nous ne pouvons
qu'être défavorables à votre amendement
et pour l'amendement 5 pour les mêmes
raisons que monsieur le rapporteur nous
y sommes aussi défavorables
merci je vais donc mettre voix
successivement ces trois amendements
avec deux avis défavorables l'amendement
4 qui est pour
qui
est contre
rejeté
[Musique]
le 5 même vote
je mets aux voix l'article premier de
terre qui est pour
qui est contre
adopté je mets aux voix le premier
quater sans amendement épourd
qui est contre
adopter
je passe à l'article 2 avec deux
amendements identiques de suppressions
monsieur do sur le 6 merci monsieur le
Président donc l'article 2 prévoit de
déroger à titre expérimental à
l'interdiction de l'usage de
l'authentification biométrique pour les
grands événements afin de permettre de
contrôler l'accès aux zones on arrive là
au cœur de la présente proposition loi
puisque au cœur de son hypocrisie si je
puis dire puisqu'en effet les articles
précédents établissent un régime général
d'interdiction d'encadrement et de
contrôle nous entrons déjà dans une
série d'exception d'autorisation
d'expérimentation qui sont en réalité le
but premier de cette PPL avec un
objectif clair et tendre peu à peu
l'usage de la biométrie dans l'espace
public expérimentation c'est une
stratégie utilisée afin de permettre un
premier contact entre les pouvoirs
publics et ces méthodes de surveillance
biométrique l'enjeu in-finé c'est d'en
créer les technologies dans les
territoires et de les normaliser dans
notre environnement leur existence
physique permet de les pérenniser et les
légaliser le système paraff dans les
aéroports est un exemple de déploiement
visant à banaliser ces technologies et
ses précisément l'objet de cet article 2
de créer un phénomène d'accoutumance
pour l'accès dans les stades ou les
concerts la pratique rentrera plus
facilement dans les mœurs c'est pour ça
c'est ce que nous souhaitons éviter
voilà pourquoi nous proposons la
suppression de cet article attentatoire
aux libertés publiques
la présidente oui merci monsieur le
Président en fait il est défendu mais
j'ai quand même une question parce
qu'après l'examen du texte en commission
il nous a été dit que les dispositifs de
d'authentification biométrique
obligatoire ne pourront concerner les
habitants de zone concernées par la mise
en place de ce système ceci devront donc
disposer d'un moyen alternatif pour
rejoindre leur domicile est-ce que
il serait possible de nous donner des
précisions sur ce point précisément je
vous remercie
si
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président nous avons
passé un moment à fixer un certain
nombre de garantie commune pour l'usage
dérogatoire de l'arc des sens faciale
dans l'espace public et voilà qu'au
moment d'examiner la possibilité de se
dérogations nous sommes saisis
d'amendement de suppression alors à quoi
sert le travail que nous venons de faire
je dois ajouter pour répondre à la
question de madame assassy qui est fort
pertinente comme toujours que en réalité
nous avons justement par une assise
prévue que les riverains d'un grand
événement ne serait pas
assujetti à
l'expérimentation qui figure ici de la
reconnaissance faciale pour l'accès à
certains lieux du grand événement ça
peut être une rue par exemple sauf s'ils
y consentait et bien s'il n'y consomme
pas et que la sécurité exige qu'il
prouve qu'ils sont bien résidents de
cette rue on contrôler a leur identité
comme on le fait depuis toujours pour
assurer la sécurité d'un lieu public en
cas de menace criminelle ou terroriste
en tous les cas nous avons après mur
délibération rejeté ces deux amendements
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président donc je
pense que je rappelais la vie de sagesse
du gouvernement sur cette ppel et dire
pour les mêmes raisons monsieur le
rapporteur que supprimer cet article
après tout ce travail et tous ces débats
ne nous paraît pas pertinents donc nous
émettons à la fois sur l'amendement 6 et
sur l'amendement 13 un avis défavorable
très bien je vais mettre voie d'abord
l'amendement enfin les deux petits sont
identiques si c'est 13 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
ils sont rejetés
l'article 2 donc on voit qui est pour
qui contre
il est adopté
à l'article 3 un amendement 7 et un
abonnement catholique normalement 7
monsieur dessus merci monsieur le
président
l'article 3 de la présente proposition
prévoit la mise en oeuvre de logiciels
de traitement automatisé de donner
biométrique pour rassembler des preuves
retrouver l'auteur ou la victime d'une
infraction sur des images recueillies
dans le cadre d'investigation mais
malgré les garanties supplémentaires
ajoutées en commission notre groupe
s'oppose par principe à l'utilisation
automatiqueée des données biométriques
des quarts de fou issus de la Commission
ne tiendront pas longtemps les
antécédents de généralisation de ce
genre de pratique sont connues
aujourd'hui on met le doigt dans un
engrenage certains dont il sera
difficile de revenir et donc pour éviter
l'effet cliquet évoqué par mon collègue
du Rhin nous proposons donc la
suppression de cet article
madame la Présidente assassy le 14 merci
monsieur le Président concrètement il
s'agit ici de permettre l'usage de
logiciels de reconnaissance faciale sur
les données les données contenues dans
le Tage le traitement des antécédents
judiciaires or ce fichier dont nous
avions d'ailleurs dénoncé la création et
tentaculaire et près de 19 millions de
fiches sont présentes dans ce méga
fichier qui contient des informations à
la fois sur les personnes mises en cause
peu importe d'ailleurs qu'elles aient
été condamnées ou pas sur les témoins et
sur les victimes impliquées dans les
enquêtes ainsi on se retrouve dans une
situation où le recours à des logiciels
d'analyse d'image automatisées sera
serait rendu nécessaire car le Tage est
devenu si gigantesque qu'il ne peut plus
être exploité à son plein potentiel par
des humains une surveillance de masse le
fichage généralisé rend nécessaire une
autre surveillance de masse la
reconnaissance faciale généralisée selon
encore une fois la Quadrature du Net et
donc c'est bien pour cela que nous
sommes opposés à cette partie qui
justifie toutes les fuites monsieur le
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
identiques
non chers collègues on ne peut pas
accepter vos amendements pour une raison
très simple c'est que vraiment nous
avons ici pris des précautions énormes
on pourra utiliser ce qu'on appelle la
reconnaissance faciale a postériori
c'est-à-dire avec des images qui sont
déjà enregistrés que pour des crimes sur
les dates aux personnes punies de plus
de 50 prisons pour des agressions
terroristes pour la recherche de disparu
pour la recherche de criminels et donc
les conditions sont très restrictives
c'est un magistrat qui décide c'est pas
un simple agent de police judiciaire qui
exécute c'est un officier de police
judiciaire et par conséquent toutes les
garanties sont là
pour que cette technologie soit mise au
service de la justice et de la sécurité
de nos concitoyens sont courir de
risques pour la protection de nos
libertés bien sûr à vie défavorable
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président alors sur
les deux articles donc je rappelle sur
l'article dont je rappelle les deux
amendements que nous traitons
c'est-à-dire 7 et 14
pour les mêmes raisons qu'évoquées un
peu plus un peu plus tôt nous sommes
comme nous l'avons dits sur le fond mais
par contre nous sommes défavorables sur
les deux amants
très bien je mets aux voix donc ces deux
amendements avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
qui est contre
acheter le 18 monsieur le rapporteur
rédactionnel
se justifie par son texte même qui aura
convaincu nos collègues naturellement
madame la ministre vous êtes convaincus
sur le 18 oui favorable et bien le 18 de
la commission avec la vie favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
il est adopté je vois l'article 3 qui
est pour
qui contre
il était adopté
je passe à l'article 4a avec un
amendement 8 monsieur dessus je veux
dire défendu sur celui-ci tu avais du
rapporteur
nous avons justement pris des
précautions qui n'existent pas jusqu'à
présent puisque la consultation des
antécédents judiciaires se fait sur la
base d'un décret nous avons décidé
qu'elle ne pourrait se faire que sur la
base de la loi encore faut-il l'écrire
c'est ce que nous faisons nous sommes
donc contre cette amendement
la même avis que rapporteur
je mets aux voix l'amendement 8 avec
deux avis défavorables qui pour
monsieur dessus vous êtes pour oui qui
est contre
il est resté je mets je vois l'article
4a qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté à l'article 4 un
amendement neuf monsieur
défendu défendu à vie du rapporteur
défavorable avait du gouvernement mais
ma vie je mets aux voix l'amendement
neuf avec deux avis défavorables qui
pour
bon monsieur dossud-office
qui est contre
il est rejeté je mets aux voiles article
4 qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté je passe à l'article 5
avec deux amendements identiques dessus
pression le 10 d'abord monsieur dossus
oui merci monsieur le Président donc on
arrive à l'utilisation en temps réel de
la reconnaissance faciale le grand bon
en avant dans la société de surveillance
donc la protection de nos concitoyens et
des intérêts de la nation et l'affaire
de tous en l'état les réponses apportées
par ce texte pour y parvenir font fi des
erreurs et des biais technologiques
biométriques qui ont mal conçu peuvent
entraîner l'aggravation des mots qu'il
prétend combattre le développement
expérimental de cette société de
surveillance se fait au mépris des
droits et libertés collectives placé en
garde-fou la consultation de la CNIL
pour avis ne constitue pas une garantie
suffisante en effet en poussant la CNIL
à accompagner les entreprises dans le
développement des technologies
biométriques les auteurs de cette
proposition de loi induisent à penser
qu'une société de surveillance vertueuse
est possible nous pensons l'exact
inverse chaque pouce de terrain perdu
pour nos libertés publiques nous
rapprochent des régimes autoritaires dès
lors nous nous proposons la suppression
de l'article 6 qui permettra s'il est
opté au service de renseignement du
premier cercle de mettre en oeuvre en
temps réel un traitement algorithmique
et biométrique sur les images collectées
en temps réel au détriment de nos
libertés publiques je remercie c'est
identique le 15 madame la Présidente
assassy défendu monsieur le président le
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
identiques de suppression
la proposition de loi prévoyait à une
décision du préfet exécutée par un
officier de police judiciaire sous le
contrôle du tribunal administratif le
texte de la Commission prévoit une
décision du Premier ministre après avis
de la Commission nationale de contrôle
des techniques de renseignements sous le
contrôle du Conseil d'État les garanties
sont donc maximales et il s'agit
uniquement de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et seuls les services chargés
de la sécurité intérieure pourront
mobiliser l'instrument de la
reconnaissance faciale c'est la raison
pour laquelle la Commission a constitué
que ces amendements n'étaient plus
justifiés compte tenues de l'importance
des garanties qui sont offertes et qui
reposent sur l'expérience acquise par
l'application de la loi de 2015 sur le
renseignement avis défavorable merci
madame la ministre
président
amateur votre amendement de suppression
me donne l'occasion de dire que j'ai non
pas une opposition de principe comme
vous vis-à-vis de cet article mais de
Lourdes réserves sur le dispositif
envisagé la technique de renseignement
créé par cet article ne répond à notre
avis à aucun besoin clairement défini
soit l'objectif est de sécuriser un
grand événement n'empêchant l'accès des
individus suivis par les services de
renseignement et le recours à une
technique de renseignement semble en
pratique très compliqué
soit l'objectif est de localiser en
urgence un individu présentant une
menace une menace imminente pour l'ordre
public et là encore le dispositif ne
paraît pas adapté serait plus opportun
d'une part d'autoriser l'exploitation
des caméras de vidéoprotection plutôt
que de s'appuyer sur des caméras dédiées
dans le déploiement serait complexe dans
une situation d'urgence et la couverture
géographique probablement peut
pertinente d'autre part pour être
réellement efficace il paraît plus
intéressant de permettre aux forces de
sécurité intérieure et non pas au seul
service de renseignement d'y avoir accès
donc notre avis est défavorable et nous
rappelons notre avis de sagesse sur le
projet de loi la proposition de loi
merci madame monsieur dossier
oui dans ma discussion générale j'en ai
parlé mais il y a actuellement un
conflit entre Beauvau et Matignon sur la
notion de terrorisme et Matignon pour
l'instant bloc les demandes d'écoute
d'un certain nombre de militants
écologistes qui sont visiblement
considérés comme terroristes par notre
ministre de l'Intérieur et donc on a là
un problème de conception parfois
extensive de cette notion là et donc les
garde-fous pour nous de cet article ne
sont pas suffisants
oui on est avec ces articles sur le cœur
du cœur des difficultés
dans le contexte d'inquiétude dans la
société vis-à-vis des techniques de
renseignement
l'actualité récente nous a montré
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait eu à Matignon
il y a quelques semaines une
autorisation sans aucun contrôle de
technique de renseignement qui sont
supposés être particulièrement contrôlés
donc même quand les garde-fous sont très
puissants il peut arriver que on passe
outre et nous sommes que ces techniques
d'identification en temps réel malgré
les précautions qui ont été proposées
sont au vu de ce que j'indiquais dans
mon propos liminaire tout à l'heure et
un peu dans le droit fil de ce que
disait madame la ministre
prématuré au vu de la qualité du débat
et de la possible utilisation de la
reconnaissance faciale dans un cadre
sécuritaire plus globalement défini
très bien je mets aux voix ces deux
amendements identiques avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour
qui est contre
ils sont rejetés je mets aux voiles
article 5 qui est pour
qui est contre
adopter
je passe à l'article 6 avec deux
amendements identiques le 11 monsieur
dessus merci monsieur le Président nous
considère qu'il y a pas de retour en
arrière possible si on commence à
utiliser l'utilisation en temps réel des
technologies de reconnaissance faciale
il peut y avoir qu'un glissement
continue vers la surveillance globale
nous voyons pas quoi qui peut l'arrêter
c'est de ce n'est pas notre modèle de
société nos libertés publiques sont
menacées par ce texte par la
dissémination et la prolifération des
technologies de surveillance leur
interdiction doit être le principe
absolu la reconnaissance biométrique
imparfaite peut entraîner des erreurs de
raisonnement aux conséquences multiples
et potentiellement graves tels que des
arrestations
erronées par les forces de l'ordre on
s'intéressant au profil des personnes
victimes de ces erreurs la Défenseur des
droits a bien insisté sur ses risques il
s'agissait majoritairement de personnes
issues de groupe déjà discriminés ou
vulnérables en raison de biais
discriminatoire des algorithmes sur
lesquels repose ces technologies
j'insiste sur ce point les enquêteurs
ont suffisamment de moyens de
surveillance à leur disposition pour ne
pas avoir à laisser un énième outil de
surveillance qui n'a pas fait ses
preuves et qui comporte une grande marge
d'erreur d'appréciation merci le 16
madame la présentata
ce président les auteurs de ces
amendements ont raison sur un point on
arrive là à la pointe extrême de ce que
nous pouvons envisager c'est à dire
qu'il s'agit plus d'utiliser des images
préexistantes dans le cadre d'une
enquête judiciaire je le rappelle
c'est-à-dire sous l'autorité de
magistrats il s'agit de créer l'image
par une surveillance qui doit permettre
de d'identifier les auteurs d'un crime
particulièrement grave alors je veux
préciser que si cette
possibilité d'emploi de la technologie
de la reconnaissance faciale
ne doit en aucun cas généralisé il nous
paraît possible de l'expérimenter à
condition de le faire de manière
extrêmement restrictive c'est la raison
pour laquelle les finalités de
l'expérimentation ce ne pourront être
que des enquêtes portant sur des actes
de terrorisme des atteintes aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation des
infractions relatives à la grande
criminalité organisée et la disparition
d'enfants qui aurait été enlevé et puis
bien sûr si on veut prolonger au-delà de
48 heures cette surveillance exercée
sous le contrôle d'un juge il faudra
demander au juge des libertés de la
détention ça veut dire que il vérifiera
évidemment que l'enjeu est tel que ce
privé du recours à la reconnaissance
faciale serait une perte de chance pour
la justice dans la lutte contre la
grande criminalité merci madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président sur les
amendements 11 et 16 donc nous pensons
que pouvoir faire de la reconnaissance
faciale pour des finalités judiciaires
répond en réalité à un vrai besoin pour
autant le dispositif envisagé ne nous
paraît pas suffisamment opérationnel la
commission des lois notamment supprimée
la possibilité d'avoir recours à cette
technologie afin d'identifier une
personne en fuite alors qu'il s'agirait
là d'un des intérêts majeurs et assez
légitime de se dispositif de plus les
conditions de mise en oeuvre ne semble
pas compatibles avec la nature et la
gravité des infractions dont le
dispositif entend facilité la poursuite
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons nous
sommes défavorables à l'article en
l'état mais nous ne sommes pas pour
autant favorables à la suppression pour
les pour les raisons que je viens
d'invoquer donc avis défavorable
et bien je vais mettre voix donc ces
deux amendements identiques avec deux
avis défavorables qui pour
quiconque
ils sont rejetés le 19
monsieur le rapporteur
rédactionnel madame la ministre madame
la ministre le 19
rédactionnel
favorable au nom du gouvernement le 19
de la commission avec avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre il était adopté je mets
où à l'article 6 qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
7 et 8 sont supprimés je me vois
l'article 9 qui est pour
[Musique]
il est adopté je vais mettre voilà
l'ensemble la proposition de loi je
précise tout de suite que je suis saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe socialiste
sur l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
à plus personne ne demande à voter
allez monsieur Verde vous avez 30
secondes pour voter
au fait ce que vous voulez remarquer moi
j'ai pas des tadames mais que vous êtes
rentrés dans l'hémicycles ou je demande
si plus personne ne demande à voter vous
avez le droit
on sent qu'il y a un suspense
insoutenable donc faut vraiment que vous
fassiez pression
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
votre temps 343 exprimé 343 pour 226
contre 117 la proposition de loi est
adoptée
je vais suspendre la science quelques
instants sur place afin de laisser la
Commission au gouvernement le temps de
s'installer pour l'examen du prochain
texte merci madame la ministre